so twitter kriegt man wieder die vorschau nicht richtig hin
ah jetzt, exellent moin nico
habt ihr was beim prime day bestellt ist ja noch gut ist ja noch kaum einer da ich habe ja ich
habe zwar geschrieben auf twitter dass fast alles blöd ist blödsinnig ist beim prime day
allerdings ich habe mir doch ein paar sachen bestellt kann ich euch kann ich euch gleich mal
zeigen was ich bestellt habe nix nix nix bahnbrechendes ein paar sachen die ich eh schon die ganze zeit
bestellen wollte exellent naja so wie gesagt ich habe nichts großartiges geplant konnte uns ein
paar sachen angucken und ich habe es jetzt geschafft ich habe es jetzt geschafft ich habe mir hier
in ich habe mir hier so einen sick be thermostat gekauft um die heizung automatisch einzustellen so
moment aber nicht für den preis das hat das letzte mal noch 39 39 euro gekostet wtf aber
viel zu teuer also ich kaufe mir das ich kaufe das hat übelst das ist übelst teurer geworden
also ich habe mir für 39 euro mal zum testweise und sick be thermostat bestellt weil das ist ja
so eine sache die heim automatisierungstechnisch an mir noch ein bisschen vorbeigegangen ist und
zwar die heizungs also die die heizkörper zu zu steuern ich habe es jetzt so dass die heizung
automatisch ausgeht um 22 aber natürlich wenn man die temperatur direkt an der heizung steuern
könnte wäre deutlich cooler natürlich wie gesagt wir kaufen das ganze auf aliexpress wir kaufen
das nicht wie bei amazon oder so und ich habe jetzt nur mal ein bestellt auf amazon und das
werden wir in einem der nächsten streams ausprobieren und genau wie das wie das ganze
zu funktionieren ich habe es ich habe schon gepaart aber richtig richtig gut funktioniert
das ganze guckt der versand ist halt zu teuer na gut wie dem auch sei wer ist hier noch alles
am start qualok skill killer gpad 1 hd da fehlt noch irgendwie sowas wie xx hd oder sowas davor
der flow 690 der phoenix der patrick ist am start x hack hacky x delay plans versus zombies
stream habe ich nicht letztes jahr weihnachten habe ich nicht doch vor zwei jahren vor zwei
jahren im januar habe ich irgendwo plans for zombies gestreamt der discor welches plans
für zombies denn eins oder oder 2 2 habe ich noch nie gespielt aber 2 ist halt so ein pay
to win ding das handy game ist in beides handy games das erste ok ich hätte ich tatsächlich
mal wieder bock drauf ja ich meine es ist schon irgendwie eigentlich ist übelst langweilig so
toll die fans zu gucken aber da hätte ich da hätte ich tatsächlich mal wieder richtig bock
drauf dann gibt es erstmal custom firma flow 690 so wie sieht es aus leona bomba 97 14 monate
krass auch scheiß das ist ja schon moment ich muss ich muss mein passendes emote raussuchen
excellent bisschen groß wobei 14 monate passt schon aber das wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht
einblenden ich wollte ich wollte das hier sagen moment so hast du sich die repeater am start hat
mir ein osram plug gekauft nein habe ich nicht ich wollte mir allerdings zwei von ikea kaufen weil
ich gelesen habe dass diese osram plugs lustig dass du es ansprichst weil die nicht so gut sind
also das ist ja sich wie ist ja im vergleich zu wlan funktioniert ist ja ein bisschen anders das
ist ja so eine mesh struktur also sprich sich wie und sie wir es das sind wir es nicht kennt das
sind zwei standards für lo ultra low power geräte in daheim für vorheim automatisierungszwecke und
die reichweite von sich wie und sie war es ist nicht so gut deswegen machen die das so geräte
die am strom angeschlossen werden also in die steckdose kommen die machen quasi so ein mini
repeater auf und verbinden sich mit allen anderen geräten so das gibt dann so eine mesh struktur wie
so ein netz von jedem gerät zu jedem gerät so und quasi mit so die idee ist dass man sich wie und
sie wo f quasi mit geräten die an den strom angeschlossen werden dass man dort quasi sein
netz aus aus 69 zuschauer gerade ausweite das funktioniert mit sie wo f ziemlich gut mit sie
mit sich bin nicht so zumindest hat es bei mir nicht gut funktioniert aber ich muss dazu sagen
ich habe sich die sachen auch erst seit drei tagen am start und ich habe ich mir das eigentlich
ich habe mir das eigentlich dafür gekauft wie gesagt mal hier so ein thermostat auszuprobieren
ich habe mir noch anderen sensor gekauft und ich habe diesen stick aber wie gesagt das machen wir
alles in einem der nächsten der nächsten streams ich habe den ich habe den stick gekauft hier
konbi konbi stick konbi 2 und danach ist mir aufgefallen richtig richtig lowbrane war das
richtig lowbrane danach ist mir aufgefallen ich habe den konbi v1 noch da der hat genauso gut
funktioniert ich habe nämlich mal nachdem ich den konbi 2 bestellt habe der ist angekommen da
habe ich noch meine amazon bestellung durchgesucht habe festgestellt ich habe mir vor zwei hat schon
mal konbi 1 bestellt ich finde es schön wie du den stream als rechtfertigung brauchst um
random zeugs zu kaufen rum zu basteln ne das wollte ich auch so machen aber es ist natürlich
immer gut wenn man das verbinden kann zwischen was ich eh machen will und stream das ist
optimal 15 monate exquisite subscription ja so und also plans für zombie stream wie gesagt
können wir machen an weihnachten irgendwann ich habe ja bald ich habe bald eineinhalb monate
urlaub dauert gar nicht mehr so lang guck mal leute ich habe bald kalender 2020 ich lese gleich chat
durch sehler schon ein paar sachen drin so guck mal ich habe jetzt schon den kompletten december
eh urlaub eingetragen und ich habe dann glaube ich sogar noch sechs tage übrig oder so oder
acht tage übrig zumindest zumindest ich kann quasi noch die woche nehmen und die woche also
ich bin jetzt quasi nur noch 1 2 3 4 wochen wo ich auf die arbeit gehen muss dann ist dann ist
vorbei für dieses jahr und dann habe ich urlaub 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 wochen also wenn das mal nicht
ist ja gut ich hätte ja normalerweise noch mehr urlaub weil wenn man fünf tage woche arbeitet
bekommt man ja mehr und ich arbeite ja nur vier tage woche deswegen habe ich nur wieviel
urlaubstage habe ich eigentlich ich glaube 24 übrigens bei the way also das ist ja auch
ein thema was wir hier immer was was wir hier immer im stream haben die also ich weiß norwegen
norwegen hat das ja jetzt standardmäßig dass oder war das finnland nee das war norwegen
ich glaube norwegen die haben das wohl jetzt schon ziemlich was norwegen in skandinav entweder
überlegen dies gerade dass das quasi so die standards arbeitswoche zu machen sie haben es
schon also das finde ich ist richtig geile idee und ich kann es wirklich jedem nur empfehlen ich
habe selbstens dem m core der hat auch mal wieder gestriemt vielleicht kennt noch der ein oder
andere von früher auch letztens im stream nahegelegt alter wenn dir die arbeit zu viel
wird mach vier tage woche und ich kann das auch nur jedem weil ich sag's jetzt so wir haben das
hier oft im stream als thema ich kann das wirklich nur jedem empfehlen das zu machen gerade jetzt so
der jahreswechsel biete sich das an vielleicht noch mal zu seinem chef zu gehen wer was machen
will voraus jetzt natürlich man kommt mit der kohle über die runde aber die sache ist die
sag ich jetzt mal ganz kurz aus meiner sicht die vorteile was vier tage woche ausmacht an
die anderen sachen im chat beantworte ich gleich also was war was aus meiner sicht halt dass das
beste ist was vier tage woche angeht also das erste ist es ist nicht so viel geld weniger dadurch
dass ein bisschen weniger geld verdient müsste ein bisschen weniger steuer bezahlen und das macht
alles in allem könnte man schon sagen es ist dann halt quasi dann 20 15 moment ich so um die 20
prozent 15 15 20 prozent ist dann ist dann weg aber wenn man sonst mit seiner kohle auskommt und man
das verkraften kann es es hört sich erstmal viel an aber von dem was dann am ende am konto
wirklich weniger ankommt ja es ist weniger aber es ist nicht so dass man sagen würde ok ich
komme jetzt super aus und ohne ich muss verhungern also es ist immer merkt das wirklich also ich
habe es nicht großartig gemerkt gut ich hatte zu der zeit aber auch noch dicke youtube einnahmen
und jetzt habe ich ja noch ein bisschen nebenbei immer noch aber natürlich youtube youtube habe
ich übrigens letzten monat wisst ihr ratet mal wie viel wie viel youtube money habe ich letzten
monat bekommen ich habe es euch schon verraten 17 euro 17 euro ich habe es euch aber schon
gesagt weil sonst hätte nicht so viele leute 17 euro gesagt wie viel war das meiste das ist
schwer zu sagen also ich würde sagen zu als ich so richtig viel gemacht habe auf youtube wo ich
dann auch teilweise elgato zeug gemacht habe g2a gemacht habe irgendwelche video geschichten
keine ahnung also ich könnte mir vorstellen dass es schon mal monate gab aber das ist wohlgemerkt
ich sage es geht darum was das meiste war das ist ich sage ich kann dir das war wirklich bei
weitem nicht die regel aber wenn alles wirklich mal so wenn die sterne mal in der richtigen
formation gestanden haben so 45.000 euro im monat einmalig so wenn wirklich alles zusammengekommen
ist wer klar war glaube ich ungefähr das höchste was es jemals gegeben hat das war aber auch ein
monat das war glaube ich december da gab es massig amazon da habe ich elgato auszahlung
bekommen da habe ich g2a plus g2f links bekommen und ich habe glaube ich mit ein video noch was
gemacht das war das war quasi so ein monat das war hier wirklich exquisite alien wehralde hör mal
auf ich weiß gar nicht wie ich weiß kann mich da überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern naja so
war ich jetzt war ich jetzt gerade dabei genau also wie gesagt kann ich jedem nur empfehlen dass
das das zu probieren und der größte vorteil von der vier tage woche mann nachteil habe ich
jetzt ja schon gesagt kriegt ein bisschen weniger kohle aber da meine ich noch größte
vorteil von der vier tage woche ist man hat mehr gibt man hat gefühlt doppelt so viel zeit das
klingt jetzt erst mal blöd weil das ist ja nur ein tag mehr aber ihr könnt den tag so planen wie
ihr euch gut passt ich bei mir ist es montag zum beispiel der hintergrund warum ich mal warum ich mal
montag genommen habe ist folgender weil ich mir gedacht habe ok da sind die leute die kommen aus
dem wochenende sind motiviert und ich habe diese ich habe den tag frei mal genommen dass ich mich
mehr um youtube geschichten kümmern kann also war mal so der ursprüngliche plan da dachte ich ja
kommen die leute aus dem wochenende da sind die marketing stonks menschen motiviert montags ist
gut und außerdem gleichermaßen bei uns auf der arbeit sind die leute montags teilweise echt
übertrieben nervig weil du jetzt nicht mehr so wir hatten paar leute die waren dann immer so
so die hatten so die ultra antrieb montags immer wir hatten früher auch ein chef da ist montag
immer dann übelst ab was was montag montag ist wunderbar und aber es ist eigentlich egal ob
freitag oder montag ich finde aber am besten wenn es wenn es am stück ist und ja warum man so doppelt
so viel zeit hat wie also warum man gefühlt doppelt so viel zeit hat ist ganz einfach
wenn man arbeiten geht dann ist der tag meistens so du kommst dann irgendwann ich sag mal 16 30 17
30 manche vielleicht sogar 18 30 erst heim bei mir 16 30 da bist du ziemlich kaputt da machst du
nicht mehr allzu viel sondern das machst du noch freitag freitag bist du auch noch kaputt ich
weiß wenn man noch jung ist mit 20 oder so dann ist das juckt es ein nicht dann ist man danach
trotzdem noch voll fit und kann was machen aber ich kann euch sagen man ist ja schon ganz schön
kaputt und dann machst du freitag nicht mehr großartig was da machst du samstag das was du
machen musst zum beispiel irgendwelche sachen einkaufen und das problem ist das muss jeder
samstag machen dementsprechend fangen nicht die leute samstag auf viel mehr ab als unter der woche
da musst du die sachen freitag muss samstags bis mittags mal das schläft das mal aus muss
samstag bis mittag das erledigen was du was du erledigen musst dann hast du frei dann hast du frei
hast du frei kannst samstag was machen manch einer geht was weiß ich geht sich dann besaufen oder so
ihr wisst ja ich große menschenersammlung sind nicht meins aber jeder was er jeder was er will
so und dann kannst du sonntag noch mal ausschlafen mittels sonntag ich weiß meine frage an wie es
euch geht mir ging sonntags immer so dass ich so ab sonntag 14 uhr 15 uhr gedacht habe ach scheiße
morgen musst ja wieder arbeiten gehen vielleicht was weiß ich gehst jetzt noch mal gehst jetzt
noch mal duschen machst dich irgendwie schon mal ein bisschen fertig legst dein zeug unten schon
mal hin oder war schon quasi ab sonntag mittag ist schon fast schon wieder arbeit fängt an so
und das hat man nicht mit einem tag mehr und man hat es so doof es klingt auch montags nicht weil
man einen tag mehr frei hatte also ich muss sonntags denke ich überhaupt nicht dran dass ich arbeiten
gehen muss weil muss ich ja auch nicht weil ich muss habe ja montags frei und montags hatte ich
dann quasi drei tage in folge quasi zeit wo ich was machen konnte was ich was ich gerne mache wo
ich mich ausruhen konnte das heißt montags bis montags abends interessieren mich das überhaupt
nicht dass ich mich interessiert eigentlich bis ich aufstehen muss nicht und ich bin dann auch
viel wacher und fitter das ist super also ich kann es wirklich nur empfehlen mit der sich das
geldmäßig zutraut dass es das das aushält das bisschen weniger geld es ist eigentlich für alle
beteiligten das beste man ist weniger genervt es gehen an die leute weniger auf dem keks man macht
auch bessere arbeit im endeffekt dadurch dass man ausgeruhte ist also ich kann das wirklich
jedem nur empfehlen der das irgendwie finanziell halbwegs verkraften würde ein bisschen weniger
kohl also wie gesagt ist meiner mein nach ganz ganz tolle geschichte so als wo ich mal kurz auf den
fragt das mal den chef wenn man einem systemrelevanten beruf arbeitet dann soll
die einfach mehr leute einstellen ich weiß ich weiß es ist so einfach ist es nicht aber ich
finde sollte man jedem ermöglichen und gerade den leuten die in systemrelevanten jobs arbeiten
gerade die müsstest du eh entlasten weil das sind keine wir hocken am schreibtisch und drehen
däumchen jobs das sind meistens sachen mit sehr viel verantwortung und ich meine ich meine jetzt
nicht ich meine jetzt nicht die weit bleibt ab was war zwar ab wer das sind meistens dass
den meist mit sehr viel verantwortung ich meine das nicht irgendwelche stonks manager da kann man
vielleicht auch von verantwortung sprechen aber jemand der im krankenhausarbeit oder daten pflegen
der hat meiner mein noch eine andere art von verantwortung und dazu kommt dass diese jobs
nicht nur körperlich sehr anstrengend sind sondern psychisch auch und man eben auch sehr
eingespannt ist bei der ganzen sache das heißt gerade diese gruppen die müsstest du eigentlich
entlasten und ich finde es auch ein absolutes unding dass man anfangen von dieser ganzen corona
geschichte großartig rumgetönt hat hier krankenschwestern sonst was ihr seid unsere
hellen und haben gesungen vom balkon und so was gesagt ja ihr kriegt alle mehr kohle und jetzt
wo die sache vorbei ist hat man sich gedacht leck mich machen wir einfach nicht das ist das ist
komplett das ist das ist so scheiße wenn man es mal wenn man es mal so sieht das ist absolut unding
dass da nicht mehr drüber drüber gesprochen wird oder mehr mehr druck gemacht wird auf allen seiten
kann ich nicht verstehen es scheint es scheint auch kein zu jucken der applaus bezahlt die miete
genau das das scheint auch irgendwie kein zu jucken so wirklich dass das das juckt immer nur
leute wenn es an eigenen kragen geht wenn dann mal einer wirklich ist auslöffeln muss dass es
zu wenig krankenpfleger gibt oder zu wenig alte pflege dann ist dann wird dann wird groß rumgeheult
so nach dem man das ist machen wir den herz und auch das hat er politik versagt und so obwohl man
es sieht es ist offensichtlich es ist es wird an so vielen stellen versagt in dieser in dieser und
ganz beim bei anderen sachen auch man weiß es ja aber es juckt kein wie wir wie reagieren uns lieber
an anderen themen ab wo man sich dann moralisch ganz groß und toll fühlen kann zum beispiel wenn
er max auf twitter schreibt ein chineser hat ich weiß ich auch gott hab ich weiß ich auch
was gelesen hat von aufwetter wenn er max zum beispiel auf twitter schreibt dass ein chineser
einer made of china steckdose designt hat das ist das ist ultra rassistisch da musste dich gleich
schon mal da musste dich gleich schon mal richtig empören auf twitter und sagen max du alter rassist
hier ist ja quasi stell dir mal vor du wärst 1988 geboren das ist ja quasi kann gleich schon
ja ja also twitter deutschland ist echt so ein eigenes ding ja justin 999 sagt ich muss
den chat aufmachen dass man hoch scrollen kann später justin 999 sagt wenn du dich auf andere
verlassen muss dann bist du verlassen ja ist meine meine rede ich sag es oft ich sag es oft
im stream und ich finde das unglaublich deprimierend ehrlich gesagt dass es so ist ja ich finde es
auch sehr schade dass sich das in diese richtung entwickelt hat das problem was ich sehe ist das
kommt ja nicht von ungefähr also die leute denken sich ja nicht von heut auf morgen so nach dem motto
ich bin jetzt ein egoistischer sack das denkt sich ja keiner von heute auf morgen wenn er denn
nicht eh schon die einstellung hat aber das sind entwicklungen und und erfahrungen die die leute
machen dass sie nicht um um hinkommen irgendwann zu diesem schluss zu kommen wenn man einfach 20
jahre lang merkt ok es macht in deinem interesse keiner was dann bleibt den leuten nichts anders
zu erbrechen das finde ich halt echt kacke und es wird allen besser gehen wenn die sich mal
klingt jetzt klingt jetzt drauf ja die sollen alle mal dem danae lama auf twitter folgen und sich
ein bisschen an das halten was der typ schreibt und es würde es allen viel besser gehen die leute
werden viel entspannter die werden viel die welt wäre besser aber das wird nichts kann er vergessen
dass das haut im leblichen ja und wenn du das quasi von allen stellen vorgemacht kriegst und
quasi über 20 jahre lang merkt scheiß es macht keiner was für dich dann bleibt dir
irgendwann nichts anders übrig wie zu sagen alter ich scheiß auch drauf und mache das was für
mich am besten ist auch wenn es für andere schlecht ist was halt was halt was halt sagt
das sieht man jetzt finde ich schon ein bisschen daran dass es dann so diskussionen gibt wie
was was hat letztens einer was hat letztens irgendwie einer erzählt irgendwie es sollen
keine straßen mehr gebaut werden und solche sachen so straße dem arsch wie kann man jetzt
wirklich ernsthaft dass es soll keine straßen mehr gebaut werden oder oder leute die arbeiten
gehen müssen dürfen nicht mehr in die innenstadt fahren willst du wirklich die leute treffen die
diens eh schon scheiße geht oder was ist das sinn und zweck der übung die leute zu treffen die
sie schon scheiße geht wenn es mal irgendwann so ist dass man ja und mir wäre es persönlich auch
lieber es ist eher heute als morgen wenn der nahverkehr so gut ausgebaut ist dass man sich
wirklich alle zehn minuten fährst du eigentlich auch ja ab und zu mal dass man sich alle zehn
minuten in die bahn setzen kann und dahin kommt wo man hinkommen will wunderbar wie gesagt ich
hätte es lieber dass es jetzt so ist als morgen aber man kann doch nicht den zweiten schritt vor
dem ersten machen und den leuten verbieten auf die arbeit zu fahren in die innenstadt solange die
voraussetzten noch gar nicht da sind und finden und ich bin und ich bin davon überzeugt wenn die
alternativen da sind bräuchtest du so einen verbot wahrscheinlich gar nicht weil viele leute gar nicht
freiwillig nach frankfurt mit dem auto fahren sondern sie weil sie weil sie weil sie müssen
weil sie auf die bahn verlassen können ja ok ich muss jetzt mal ich muss mal kurz chat lesen weil
da gab es nämlich am anfang noch paar questions ich kreue mal ich kreue mal kurz ich kreue mal
kurz durch ich zeige euch gleich was ich mir über prime gekauft habe zum beispiel zum beispiel die
hier die wlan steckdosen die ich gerade versucht habe zu flaschen die mich übelst aufgeregt haben
aber ich gucke mal kurz gucke mal kurz durch du hast den themenvorschlag gepostet sieben
andere haben darauf reagiert dann müssen wir das wohl da müssen wir das wohl machen am freitag
er nicht an an weihnachten irgendwann was nutzt du zur heimautomatisierung testet gerade home
assistant ich verwende home assistant beste home assistant beste also gefällt mir von all ich
habe ich habe ein paar sachen durchprobiert also ich habe mir mal ab angeguckt habe ich anfälle
gekriegt wegen java ich habe wie heißt das auf perl basis femm oder so mal ausprobiert naja
gut 2020 was auf perl basis eher pains champ aber ich benutze home assistant gefällt mir auch am
besten wenn max ist im stream kauft kann er es als arbeitsmittel von der steuer absetzen das ist
6 hat das oder 11 hat das habe ich noch gar nicht gar nicht dran gedacht glaube nicht dass es funktioniert
kann man die you bridge als base physik b verwendet ja bestimmt aber halt wahrscheinlich nur für die
eigenen sachen die sache die sache bei sich b und sie war es ist folgendes sie war es ist ein ist
ein standard wo drinnen steht dass wenn ein hersteller sie war es draufschreibt dann muss
er mit dem sie war es standard kompatibel sein das also mit an mit allem kompatibel sein das
bedeutet dass du mit jedem x-beliebigen sie war es controller alles sie war es geräte steuern
kannst bei sich b ist das so da ist zwar frequenz standardisiert und so ein paar sachen aber da
können auch die hersteller proprietäre sachen drüber machen und die hersteller sind meistens
nicht so scharf drauf dass man über ihre ich nenne zwar fernbedienung alle anderen geräte
steuern kann deswegen ist das beste was du machen kannst du holst dir in den fertigen sich b hub
aber was ich aber empfehlen würde ist du holst den raspberry pi mit so einem stick hier und installierst
dann da ein deiner sich b controller deiner wahl und kannst dann darüber alles mögliche steuern
so ich kreuze im schnell durch lauf durch ich habe vorhin video aufgenommen aber kein video
für youtube aber ich kann es euch gleich mal zeigen der umut fragt max ich bin kurz davor
zu weinen oh das aber schlecht feels bad man ich habe ein net cologne anschluss bekommen und ich
brauche zwei wlan text an der warnschnitt stelle 20 für die telefonie und 10 für das internet
kriege das bei mikrotik nicht hin mikrotik wlan konfiguration ist richtig beschissen ich
kann dir sagen was ich kann dir ein ganz gutes tutorial zeigen also es gibt auf youtube eins
von so zwei prüdern aber das problem dabei ist das ist alt das ist von 2014 das funktioniert
noch was die hier zeigen das problem ist das ist eigentlich der alte weg es gibt bei mikrotik
gibt es zwei wege wlan anzulegen das oder habe es da nicht ein tutorial genau oder diese geschichte
hier nach kannst du gehen das tutorial ist eigentlich ganz gut also ich gebe dir aber
recht es ist mega beschissen wlan einzurichten in bei mikrotik und unnötig kompliziert
normalerweise bei jedem x beliebigen switch der ein bisschen besser ist als ein 10 euro tp links
switch der der geste rein sagt hier wlan text trunkport was auch immer das und das erlaubt
fertig aber nicht so bei mikrotik hi max kennst du bestimmt wlan heizungsthermostat empfehlen hat
x peter sky gefragt ich kann dir kein wlan thermostat empfehlen das problem bei wlan
thermostaten ist oder generell bei wlan geräten ist die verbrauchen so viel strom für stand
by also du kriegst ein wlan gerät nicht auf so viel auf so wenig stand by oder generell
auf so auf so einen geringen verbrauch dass du das lange laufen lassen kannst also die
meisten wlan geräte halten wenn es hochkommt dann auch schon ordentlichen akku sechs monate
wohingegen sie oder sie geräte auch mal zwei drei jahre halten also ich würde sagen guck dir
lieber passig b oder sie geräte an den habe ich mir hier gekauft allerdings kauft ihr die nicht
erstens ist der preis viel teurer geworden was lächerlich ist warum das auf einmal teurer wird
und ich habe mir das nur zum ausprobieren gekauft und qualitativ ist das nicht so geil ich werde
es mir bei aliexpress kaufen da kostet nämlich nur 21 euro ich muss mir mal einen shop suchen der
nicht so hohen versand hat die qualität ist jetzt nicht so der wahnsinn von diesem ding also das
wackelt ganz schön ich bin mir aber nicht sicher ob es wackelt weil die quali so scheiße ist oder
weil es mir runter gefallen ist mir ist runter gefallen und auseinander gebrochen also nicht
auseinander gebrochen runter gefallen und auseinander geflogen und ich muss halt wieder
zusammenstecken ja das bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher woran es liegt dass es wackelig ist aber
es funktioniert ziemlich gut so soll ich bin da bin noch mitten im chat gucken
genau tribullen so sieht es aus freitag kann man einkaufen termine erledigen
ndc das kann man auch kann man montags ich mache es meistens montag so kannst du dir nicht auch
ein partner suchen damit du wieder mehr kohle machst ich könnte bestimmt die ein oder andere
leute fragen ob die ob die bock haben hier was zu machen beziehungsweise ich kriege ja ich kriege
ja mittlerweile sogar auf die email adresse für für für high wub loss als anrede nicht mal
highmax fps aber da ist zum größten teil in den müll dabei ich könnte mal vielleicht ein paar
leuten fragen ich noch von von youtube zeug kennen aber ich will hier gar nicht so viel was soll
ich hier machen also gaming bezogenes zeug kann ich hier nicht machen ich könnte hier vielleicht
bisschen bisschen hardware zeug machen aber ich will nicht express vpn oder so ein kack bewerben
also da gibt es da gibt es nicht so viel und ich finde es ehrlich gesagt so auch ganz gut
ich meine ich werde schon nicht verhungern so ich bin gleich durch mit dem chat
so dann kommen wir gleich mal an ich habe mir nämlich paar sachen bei amazon prime beim
prime day doch doch beim prime bestellt obwohl ich gemerkt hat hab
fand doch paar ganz gute sachen dabei so wie viele leute der chat ist ja schon wieder viel
mehr gewachsen als als als ich angefangen habe zu scrollen so ich bin gleich und kennst du die
home assistant integration was was für ein ding oh was ist das what the fuck was ist das
ist so esoterik kram so was wie heilsteine oder so das ist das ist einfach nur helligkeit oder
1000 kelvin 10.000 kelvin ne kenne ich nicht sagt sagt mir gar nichts kannst du ein low power
mainboard empfehlen was mehr als 8 gigabyte ram kann das s rock also ich empfehle immer das hier
aber du hast recht das kann nur 8 gigabyte ram aber bald intel hat die neue generation schon
angekündigt bald gibt es mainboards nachfolge mainboards hiervon hoffe ich mal die dann mehr
können wo läuft ein home assistant drauf als dockercontainer ja auf so einem board hier auf
so einem fast dem bisschen anderen aber gleich cpu auf so einem board supervised also sprich
das ist das ist das ist im docker allerdings kann man das managen über die home assistant
oberfläche ja umot ist doch egal ob lan oder wl ob lan oder warn das sind beides zwei ganz
normale ports an einer mikrotik die einrichtung für den lan port oder für den warn port ist
wie landmäßig das gleiche und es ist in beiden fällen gleich kacke juby key ist eine gute sache
hast du schon das iphone 12 mini gesehen und nee hat apple endlich mal gerafft dass man auch
mal ein bisschen kleinere handys machen also sorry smart phones machen sollte ja hey das
ist ein ding moment was ist das im vergleich im vergleich versus se zeigt mal das ist das
neue se na das neue se ist ja ungefähr so groß wie ein iphone 6 oder habe ich das habe ich
das so richtig im kopf doch klar gibt es neues se dass das das ich meine das zweier das se 2
das se 2 nicht das case vom iphone 6 es gibt ein se 2020 das hier ist das ganz alte was auch immer
wie groß ist jetzt hier im vergleich ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen ihr iphone kann
mir das überhaupt nicht vorstellen wie das jetzt hier mini wo ist es denn 5, was 5, ich kann
zumindest finde ich die idee schon mal nicht schlecht dass die endlich mal kleinere kleinere
smart phones wieder bauen weil ich habe ja ein xe oder ne se se habe ich da ihr wisst besser was
ich für ein iphone habe ich habe glaube ich ein se ne kein se kein xe ne xe heißt oder ne x
achte xs xs xr das kleinere das kann doch nicht sein dass die dass ich dass die bezeichnung so
beknackt ist dass ich mal weiß was ich für ein handy habe ja ja so was hier so sieht das aus
genau genau ich weiß es wirklich nicht ich hab es doch hier liegen ich kann noch mal drauf
gucken ja moment ich muss mal kurz die hülle ich muss kurz die hülle weg machen da steht
drauf hinten wartet mal iphone warum steht da einfach nur iphone drauf jebaited da steht
einfach nur iphone drauf wahrscheinlich xr ich glaube auch xr ich glaube xr war ist das
steht in den senen ich glaube xr ich weiß dass übrigens aus dem grund nicht weil ich
das von der firma hat mir nicht selbst kauft müsste hätte ich mir das selbst gekauft dann
hätte ich das garantiert gewusst hier kann man gut ist die vergleichen okay zeigt mal
her okay compare mini versus versus 6s kann man iphone 6 nehmen iphone 6 das ist das was
ich jetzt jahrelang hatte das exzellent es ist doch nice gucken wir mal da das ist gar
nicht so viel größer ja das finde ich gut das finde ich gut wäre ein bisschen was kleineres
hier lost ist übrigens jugendwort geworden da ist der um uns sagt man muss ja über ein
port zwei vilantex mitgeben kenne pro port die methode aber nicht für ein port mit zwei
vilantex nee du musst lass mal überlegen vilan vilan konfig also du kannst bei vilans
gibts ja nur die möglichkeit entweder du text das wenn das paket raus nee warte mal
nein du gibst dem den tag wenn es über den default tag wenn es über den port reinkommt
das kann man einstellen da kann man quasi dann intervilan routing und so gedöns auf
dem router machen also sprich nach außen hin sieht man keine vilantex aber du willst
ja die andere variante haben du willst ja dass man vilantex sieht das heißt du müsstest
da sowas wie einen trunk port drauf machen denke ich würde ich jetzt mal vermuten oder
wie auch immer das genau heißt also mikrotik vilan konfig kriege ich aus dem kopf nicht
hin das ist echt wissenschaft für sich zumindest also wie gesagt ich habe damals glaube ich
sogar diesen guide dazu gelesen dass das ging du musst die ganzen vilans anlegen dann musst
du die vilans erlauben auf diesem auf dem interface also auf dem auf dem physische interface
und dann kannst du hier netze zuordnen an diesem virtuellen vilan interface und so und alles
was dann von rechnern daraus kommt kriegt das da und alles was von diesen rechnern kommt
kriegt das da aber ich kann den leider jetzt aus dem kopf nicht genau sagen gibt es eine
möglichkeit bei einer fritzbox von vodafone ein dns einzustellen keine ahnung keine fritzbox
von vodafone wenn es so eine lock down fritzbox ist dann wahrscheinlich eher nicht so also
ich wollte euch einmal kurz zeigen was ich mir beim prime day bestellt habe weil obwohl
ich gemeckert habe auf twitter dass es auf prime nichts gibt habe ich mir trotzdem was
gekauft und zwar das erste was ich mir gekauft habe sind ein paar neue batterien das ist
jetzt nicht so interessant muss ich euch nicht zeigen ich habe einen packen hiervon gekauft
weil amazon amazon amazon basics amazon eigenes zeug ist immer billig beim prime day und
eine packung moment wo steht saft die batterien heißen wirklich saft das saft
das brauche ich für ein paar geräte die wireless sind die halt so komische batterien
drin haben aber das ist jetzt nicht so spannend dann habe ich mir ein licht gekauft sowas
wollte ich schon die ganze zeit machen sowas da ich überlege das war wirklich viel viel
günstiger ich gucke gerade wo ich sehen kann was es hier gekostet ich sehe gar nicht was
es gekostet hat bei der bei der lieferung hier oder ich bin zu oder ich bin zu doof
für zumindest das habe ich mir noch gekauft das war im also die hatten viele bosch blau
dinger im angebot ja ich bin in meinen bestellung aber irgendwie sieht man das hier nicht ach
da um bestelldetails es hat gekostet äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh äh
äh äh äh äh äh
äh äh äh äh
das gleiche
skammt
skammarst
es hat genau das gleiche gekostet
na gut
kann man nix machen ne
wenn man yebated wird
dann hab ich mir noch was für ein stream gekauft
einfach nur weil es geht total sinnlos
weil ich weiß
dass ihr das gerne habt wenn ich
steckdosenleister im stream
hab ich mir noch ne andere steckdosenleister gekauft
die angeblich flashbar ist
glaub dieses teil hier
kann man angeblich flashen
steht auch in der datenbank drin
aber ich weiß dass der chat mag das
wenn ich china steckdosenleisten flasche
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht jetzt können wir nebenbei
in einem der nächsten streams dann flashen
die war aber billiger als seh ich den preis wieder net
die hat glaube ich dann nur 29
oder so gekost
so
und dann hab ich mir
und das ist das wo ich heute dran rumgebaut hab
dann hab ich mir nen vierer pack gekauft
smart steckdose
hier
diesen vierer pack hab ich mir gekauft
welchen vorteil hat das ne steckerleiste zu flashen
erstens
du brauchst nicht mehr die offizielle app
und auch nicht irgendwie
sachen über die china cloud
und das beste ist
du bekommst den web interface
wo du die steckdosenleiste bedienen kannst
und zweitens kannst du die natürlich auch
von deiner heimautomatisierung ansprechen
über http oder mqtt
was wiederum bedeutet
du bekommst ne ip steckdosenleiste
für 30 euro
was normalerweise irgendwie ab 250 euro losgeht
das ist gar nicht schlecht
so und ich hab mir davon
das war deutlich billiger
ich seh irgendwie den preis nicht
richtig fail hierbei
ich glaub das hat nur 25 euro gekostet
so und
das gute
daran ist ich hab hier geguckt
mal hier in den questions
gesucht
ob man das flashen kann
sag mal leute man konnte in den kommentaren
doch
man konnte auch bei amazon in den kommentaren
suchen
ziemlich sicher
wie ging das jetzt
das ist so das magische
wort was man suchen muss
wenn man
wissen will ob man die sachen flashen kann
tasmota also die
meistverbreitete firme
da hab ich gefunden ok
genau
ich hab nämlich hier gefunden
man kann das flashen
also ich hab mir die gekauft
weil jemand geschrieben hat es geht easy mit tuya convert
und deswegen hab ich mir die gekauft
hab es mit tuya convert probiert
das hatten wir schon ein paar mal
ein paar mal im stream
wer es nicht kennt
ich zeig das mal kurz
das ist ein projekt da braucht man
raspberry pi für
flasht solche china
also eine riesige anzahl
von china produkten kann das
übers wlan flashen mit custom firmware
ohne dass man das irgendwie aufschrauben muss
also das ist wirklich ein super
tolles tolles projekt
die machen das
so die machen nen
wlan auf was so heißt wie das
wlan wo
die chinesen dort die
dinger flashen
wie trust toller name
dann haben sie irgendwelche
private keys reverse engineered
also mit dem projekt kann man sehr
sehr sehr viele wirklich
verdammt viele china geräte
mit custom firmware flashen
ohne dass man sie aufschrauben muss
so und das hatte ich hiermit auch vor
das problem ist nur bei der ganzen
geschichte jetzt kommen wir mal zu der
wo ich jetzt eben gerade auf twitter geflamed
wurde wo ich noch ein video zu aufgenommen hab
ich hab es versucht over dr
zu flashen mit wlan
und was meint ihr
na gut das ist ne doofe frage ihr wisst schon
es hat natürlich nicht funktioniert
das ist von
also ja es hat nicht funktioniert
und das liegt daran
weil
moment
das motor
bg
was ne
wie
ist diese steckdose leiste also
muss ich dann immer erstmal das modell raussuchen
das
modell raussuchen
moment
hier
das modell raussuchen was da eigentlich
drinnen steckt weil diese sachen
funktionieren folgendermaßen es gibt
irgendwelche china hersteller was hier übrigens
ultra rassistisch ist hab ich heute
auf twitter gelernt wenn man sagt das sind
chinesen aus china und china hersteller
die
bauen
diese sorte von smart home
geräten
so
und dann gibt es
weitere hersteller die kaufen
das ab von den china hersteller
und pappen da ihr eigenes logo drauf
das heißt da steht
jetzt zwar drauf das
ist eine ai mason
smart wifi
diesen hersteller gibt es eigentlich wenn man so
will gar nicht das ist wirklich das was
da hinten nen brand also das ist wirklich
nix anderes wie jemand
der dort sein logo drauf gemacht
hat das ist alles man muss raus
bekommen welche
eigentliche china hardware darunter steckt
und das ist der hier
bsd 34
wifi plug
ist das
und ihr seht so sieht das ding aus
ohne logo und ihr werdet feststellen
dass
das sind doch ganz andere steckdosen
als die und ihr werdet feststellen das sieht
verdammt ähnlich aus außer die led
farbe
und habe ich gesehen das ganze kann man
flashen wunderbar
ja die led
farbe genau die ist übrigens rot
die ist bei mir auch gar nicht lila das das lila
ist stimmt nicht lila sind die nur zum flashen
so und wenn man das rausgefunden hat dann sieht man
ok tuya convert geht
allerdings hier ist unten der hinweis
might not be possible
wenn es neuer ist allerdings habe ich in den
amazon bewertungen
jemand gefunden der hat die dinger noch
mit tuya convert geflashed
Mitte Juli
da dachte ich mir okay
vielleicht haste glück so vier
Monate später und du bekommst
noch was mit alter firma das du es flashen kannst
ging natürlich nicht
und jetzt kommen wir dazu
der hat ein altes modell
bekommen jetzt bekommen wir dazu ich zeige euch
mal das video was ich jetzt gemacht
habe weil ich habe genau das
hier gemacht
ich habe die dinger aufgeschraubt
und von hand geflashed
und ich
wollte das video eigentlich auf twitter posten
und das video war zu lang
deswegen zeige ich euch das jetzt einfach mal
dass ihr
mal seht wie es ausschaut ich lasse
ich lasse es erstmal durchlaufen mit meinem sinnlosen
gelaber bei
übrigens wer sich dadurch getriggert
fühlt dass ich sage dass ein
chineser das made in
china produkt designt hat
der muss jetzt leider weg
hören weil
ich habe es nicht für möglich gehalten aber ich habe
vorhin auf twitter gelernt dass das leute wieder
ganz stark triggert
genau ich muss ein bisschen lauter machen
also ich habe das video
wackelig mit meinem handy unten aufgenommen
eigentlich war das für twitter gedacht
oh übrigens kann das sein
dass ich mein sound heute
wieder richtig schlecht anhört
ja
teams alter
dieses kacktool
das geht mir so auf den sack
jetzt hört sich viel besser an oder?
hört sich jetzt besser an?
ja
keine ahnung
exellent
ok gucken wir uns mal kurz das video an mal gucken ob
das laut genug ist
hallo jungs und medels hier ist der marks und ich dachte mir ich mach mal kurz das video
für die leute
die sich gefragt haben was zum teufel
habe ich da grad auf twitter gepostet
und zwar ich zeige euch das mal
ich mache mal vollbild
hallo jungs und medels hier ist der marks und ich dachte mir ich mach mal kurz das video
für die leute
die sich gefragt haben was
das ist die steckdose aus dem ding
zum teufel habe ich da grad auf twitter gepostet
und zwar ich zeige euch das mal
das ist jetzt relativ spontane geschichte mit dem iphone aus der hand
aufgenommen und zwar ich habe mir
beim amazon prime day hier so ne
Ich sitze hier gerade am Tisch unten in der provisorischen Werkstatt und bin gerade am löten.
Ich habe mir so eine Steckdose Geschichte gekauft aus beim Prime Day.
Ich habe es aber schon aufgeschraubt, da ist das Kran hier drin.
Ich musste es gerade mit einer Hand machen.
Und das ist eine WLAN Steckdose und die kann man flashen mit Custom Firmware.
Das sieht dann ungefähr so aus, wenn man etwas geflashed hat.
Ich zeige euch mal die Oberfläche.
Wenn man das geflashed hat, dann kriegt man sowas hier.
Gucken wir mal, ob ich das hier irgendwie ins Bild kriege.
Dann kriegt man sowas hier.
Und da kann man dann die Steckdose quasi ausmachen.
Oh, jetzt ist meine Lötstation ausgegangen.
Und jetzt mache ich mal hier an vom Handy.
Jetzt geht es wieder an.
Das liegt daran, weil das an der WLAN Steckdose hängt, die ich schon geflashed habe.
Das WAP-Interface ist quasi die Teil von der Custom-Firma, die ich darauf gemacht habe.
Und ich kriege echt Anfälle, Leute.
Weil die Sache ist die...
Guckt euch das mal an.
Keine Ahnung, welcher super...
Achtung, weghören!
Nicht triggern lassen!
...Designer-Chinese sich das ausgedacht hat.
Denn hier an diesem Pin, den ihr seht...
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir den überhaupt...
Also das hier unten ist easy.
Das hier dranlöten ist easy.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Zwar nicht das Schönste, aber es hält.
Bombenfest.
Kein Ding.
Aber damit man das flashen kann, muss man hier den Pin...
Und zwar den Pin dort, den seht ihr kaum.
Unten da, wo D0 dransteht.
Neben Rx.
Ja, ich glaube, man erkennt das halbwegs.
Da muss ich was dranlöten.
Ich habe es jetzt zweimal geschafft.
Und man kriegt echt Anfälle.
Das ist mini.
Das ist wirklich mini.
Ich zeige euch mal zum Verhältnis, wie groß das ist.
Hier mein Kabel, was ich da dran mache.
Guck mal, wie klein das ist, Leute.
Das ist die Spitze vom Kabel.
Ich habe euch hier mega nah dran.
Das heißt, die passt gerade so da drauf.
Und das ist wirklich ätzend, das da dran zu kriegen.
Ah ja, und wenn man das dran gelötet hat, dann kommt das hier dran.
Das ist so ein Serial auf USB-Converter.
Guck mal, wie die Dinger da dran gepappt sind.
Und dann kommt das Ganze an meinen Raspberry dran, der hier neben steht.
Guck mal, hier sogar mit Lüfter.
Mit Passivkühler, ja.
Und dort logge ich mich dann vom Handy drauf ein und starte den Flash-Vorgang,
dass ich das alles von hier unten aus machen kann.
Ja, das mache ich gerade, Leute.
Also ja, danach kommt ein bisschen Heißkleber rein.
Das Ganze ist bombenfest zu, überhaupt kein Problem.
Funktionen wunderbar.
Ja, ich dachte mir vielleicht interessiert es den einen oder anderen.
Bis dann, machts gut, CU.
Genau, das habe ich vorhin unten gemacht.
Das sind diese Steckdosen.
Ah ja, übrigens, ich zeige euch jetzt.
Jetzt muss ich ja nicht labern, jetzt kann ich mal was dazu zeigen.
Und zwar, warte mal, wir scrollen jetzt mal kurz vor.
Ja, die Twitter-Antworten waren teilweise extremst low-brain.
Und ein paar Sachen waren wirklich gut.
Das hat mir was gebracht, ja.
Ich habe vier Stück von.
Ja, eine habe ich ja schon geflasht.
Siehst du ja, hier mache ich ja über das Handy.
Dann mache ich ja hier mal eine Lötestation an und aus.
Wo er hier drauf geklickt.
Oder habe ich das schon gemacht?
Ja, genau, guck hier.
Jetzt schalte ich ja übers Handy an, die Lötestation.
Das eine habe ich schon geflasht.
Und was ist jetzt los?
Der Tanser geht wieder ab.
Fünf Stufe eins Abos. Dankeschön, Tanser.
Huge.
Wer hat denn Glück gehabt und was bekommen?
20 Rico. Der hat es verdient, der ist öfters da.
Der ist der Name, sag mir was.
Dark Nets.
Göttervogel.
FelixS45 und Babyhühnchen.
Excellent. Dankeschön, Tanser.
Huge.
Splicy Twitch Prime. Auch.
Nicer Sub. Dankeschön.
Huge Brain.
So, was ich euch jetzt eigentlich zeigen wollte, ist...
Nicht hier den Schraubendreher.
Auch nicht hier das Motoroberfläche.
Wo zeige ich denn das Ding zum Blöken? Genau.
Zeige ich es nochmal besser? Genau, hier, guck mal.
Also.
Ich habe, ich bin wirklich vorher...
Also ich rage, ich rage ganz gerne mal, wenn ich Cod spiele oder sowas, ja.
Aber wenn ich solche Sachen am Basteln bin, dann rage ich relativ selten.
Weil ich habe gemerkt, wenn man raged, dann neigt man dazu, Sachen kaputt zu machen.
Das ist auf Dauer nicht so sinnvoll.
Das heißt, wenn ich am Basteln bin, rage ich relativ selten, aber hier war ich echt stinkig.
Weil...
Hier unten, da habe ich ja gerade erzählt, hier unten das Dranlöten ist kein Ding.
Wo zeige ich es denn?
Das hier unten Dranlöten ist wirklich kein großartiges Problem hier, die Kabels.
Aber...
Hier.
Die Spitze von dem Kabel...
Hier, an diesen Pinlöten, das ist wirklich abfuck hoch zehn.
Ich habe es dann so probiert, ich habe meinen billig, billig, billigst Lötkolben genommen, weil der die kleinste Spitze hat.
Normalerweise habe ich ja dieses Ding hier.
Das da.
Ist top, also beste Lötstation ever.
Allerdings habe ich da nicht so richtig klar.
Ich habe zwar zwei Ersatz-Tipps, aber ich habe nicht diesen Millimeter-Tipp dafür.
Habe ich bis jetzt noch nicht gebraucht.
Und ich habe mir vor ein paar Jahren mal einen USB, ist kein Witz, einen USB-Lötkolben gekauft.
So einen richtig billigen kleinen Mini-Lötkolben, aber der hat eine viel kleinere Spitze.
Und damit habe ich das gemacht.
Billigst shit ist das hier, aber es hat funktioniert.
Und da musste, also ich habe wirklich rumgeraged dabei.
Und ich musste das Ganze viermal machen.
Oder dreimal, das andere habe ich gestern gemacht.
Und ich habe es jetzt so gemacht, weil vor allem dieser D0 liegt auch noch genau zwischen Reset und RX.
Also das hier entspricht den Pins von dem ESP866 oder ESP835.
Und man muss halt aufpassen, dass man nicht irgendwie RX und D0 oder Reset und D0 zusammenlöten.
Nein, man muss wirklich nur dieses Kabel einzig und allein an D0 löten.
Und nichts anderes irgendwie verbinden.
Und ihr seht, wie klein die Spitze hier ist von, das ist wirklich gefuddelt.
Und ich habe es jetzt so gemacht, ich habe Big Brain Lösungen gefunden.
Ich löte einfach alles unten dran und dann probiere ich es oben mal.
Und wenn es nicht funktioniert, dann drücke ich es einfach mit dem Daumen dran.
Das geht.
Also ich lege dann das Kabel einfach hier drauf.
Dann hast du Flussmittel. Hätte ich machen sollen, habe ich sogar da.
Also ich habe dieses 0815 Home Anwender löts hin mit Flussmittel drin.
Aber ich weiß, was du meinst, ich habe so Paste zum draufschmieren.
Hätte ich machen sollen.
Du hast recht, habe ich sogar da.
Zumindest, ich habe es jetzt so gemacht, wenn es sich nicht gleich drauflöten lässt,
dann lege ich jetzt das Kabel hier so schräg drauf und drücke es einfach mit dem Finger drauf.
Reicht auch.
Man muss bei diesen Dingern nämlich mal sagen, die sind ziemlich robust.
Vielleicht erkennt man es auch hier, was da drauf ist.
Ich zeige es aber nicht von vorne.
Da ist ein ESP866 drauf, also quasi das, was wir auch total oft schon im Stream verwendet haben.
Aber man sieht es von der anderen Seite.
Das ist so eine Standard China CPU, die da drauf ist.
So und es ist wirklich ätzend gewesen, aber hat funktioniert.
Und jetzt habe ich die mit TASMOTA geflasht und habe ein Webinterface,
wo ich das Video drüber schalten kann.
Eine Sache, die man machen muss ist, dadurch, wenn man das hier aufbricht, damit man drankommt,
hier, so sehen die Dinge ja normalerweise aus.
Also, ich mache mal kurz Musik ein bisschen an wieder.
So sehen die Dinge ja normalerweise aus.
Hallo?
Was ist denn?
Habe ich das jetzt zugemacht?
Hier.
So sehen die Dinge ja normalerweise aus.
Das Problem ist, wenn man die aufmacht, also man muss mit dem Schraubendreher hier ein bisschen ein Loch reinhauen.
Einfach Hammer nehmen und irgendwas, was ein bisschen gefedert ist, drauf, bam, 3-4 Mal ordentlich hauen,
dann kriegt man hier ein Loch rein, dann kann man das aufmachen.
Das Problem ist nur, also man sieht das Loch danach auch gar nicht mehr wirklich.
Das Problem ist nur, dann gehen die Dinge nicht mehr richtig zu.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt da vorne einen dicken Stecker reinmache und da dran ziehe,
dann kommt mir der Deckel von der Steckdose entgegen.
Das ist natürlich nicht schön.
Es ist jetzt nicht übelst unsicher, weil das steckt dann gar nicht mehr drin, sobald es mir entgegenkommt.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht schön, wenn man beim Rausziehen eines Steckers aus der Steckdose die Steckdose in zwei Hälften zerteilt.
Deswegen mache ich Folgendes, wenn ich fertig bin mit dem Flaschen,
stopfe ich das wieder rein und mache einfach einmal rum Heißkleber und drücke es rein und gut ist.
Und das ist bombenfest.
Ich bin echt begeistert.
Ich habe vor einer Weile so eine Packen Heißkleber und so eine Heißkleberpistole gekauft.
Das ist so extrem fest.
Ich habe bei der ersten, die ich geflasht habe, war ich ein bisschen zu langsam
und habe ein bisschen zu viel Heißkleber hier oben drauf gemacht.
Ich habe es auf der einen Seite gar nicht mehr richtig reingekriegt.
So schnell ist das hart geworden und fest.
Und das ist brutal fest.
Ich habe es danach versucht mal aufzumachen und ich habe wirklich mit ganzer Kraft,
ich hätte mich da dran hängen können, das wäre nicht aufgegangen.
Da wäre eher das Ding auseinandergerissen.
Hast du getestet, ob Erde verbunden ist?
Ich habe nicht gemessen.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe das Kabel gesehen.
Also ist hier drinnen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das sieht.
Hier geht so ein schwarzer, so ein schwarzer...
Moment, ich zeige dir das mal hier auf der Seite von dem Dude.
Ich zeige dir das mal auf der...
Der hat auch noch ein paar Fotos von gemacht.
Ah ne, man sieht es jetzt gar nicht, doof.
Also hier ist, es geht von dem Stecker,
es geht von dem Stecker hier, von dem da.
Guck mal, du siehst so eine schwarze Kabel hier hinten.
Das geht hier unten an diesen dritten Anschluss da in der Mitte.
Also ja, die haben das verbunden.
Das kann man auch abschrauben, wenn man will.
Aber warum sollte man?
Also ja, haben sie gemacht.
Es scheint durchdacht zu sein.
Was genau machst du da?
Ich habe nur gerade ein Video gezeigt, was ich vorhin aufgenommen habe,
unten in meiner provisorischen Werkstatt,
wo ich versucht habe, eine China-Steckdose auseinanderzunehmen
und Customfirmen drauf zu flaschen.
Warum hast du die Steckdose eigentlich gewählt?
Weil das billig war, weil das vier Stück, die du hier hast,
für 25 Euro waren.
Was hast du, SP111?
Gibt es die auch, Amazon?
Ja, deswegen habe ich die genommen, weil die nur die Hälfte kosten.
Fast die Hälfte.
Weil gut, man kann die auf AliExpress kaufen,
dann kosten die wahrscheinlich noch weniger.
Oder auch nicht.
Deswegen habe ich mir die gekauft, weil die fast nur die Hälfte von denen kosten.
Und weil man nie genug WLAN-Steckdosen haben kann.
Und Leute, falls ihr es noch nicht wusstet,
ich zeige euch jetzt mal den Tweet des Anstoßes,
nicht den Stein des Anstoßes, den Tweet des Anstoßes,
hier, wo sie sich vorhin aufgeregt aufgetaucht hat.
Und zwar, ich habe es vielleicht nicht ganz politisch korrekt ausgedrückt,
aber es haben sich wieder Leute extrem angegriffen gefühlt,
weil ich geschrieben habe, Alter, welcher Chinese hat das designt?
Man muss dazu sagen, das ist made in China.
Und dass eine Steckdose aus China von einem Chinese designt wurde,
ich gebe zu, ist mega abwegig.
Vielleicht war es auch ein Kolumbianer oder so.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, es war ein Chinese,
der die chinesische Steckdose in China designt hat.
Oder ein Chineser, wie manche Leute sagen.
Und da war Twitter wieder richtig getriggert.
Guckt es euch mal an hier.
Richtig hardcore getriggert.
Übrigens, das hier nicht.
Big Brain.
Big Brain...
Comment.
Also wusste ich nicht, dass es sowas gibt.
Richtig gut.
So.
Und hier.
Alter.
Was ist mit der Menschheit 2020 los?
Da tut mir alles weh, wenn ich das sehe.
Ich habe es gar nicht verstanden.
Ich habe es erst gar nicht kapiert.
Ich dachte, hä?
Was meint er?
Und habe ich ihm geschrieben, ja.
Weil die Dinge in China sind.
Und ich dachte, es ist ein Troll.
Ich dachte, es ist ein Troll, aber es ist nicht.
Da steigen ja noch mehr Leute drauf ein.
Herstellungsortung gleich Designer, das ist ein Troll.
Den habe ich schon gebannt.
Der Troll öfter so komisches Zeug.
Aber der geht da noch mehr ab.
Ähm.
Das ist Big Brain.
Die haben sich da noch voll...
Die haben sich da noch voll ereifert.
Voll ereifert drüber, dass ich...
Also ernsthaft.
Die haben sich da drüber richtig krass ereifert,
dass ich geschrieben habe, alter, welcher Chinese
hat, jetzt mal in Klammern,
die Made-in-China-Steckdose-Design.
Also was mit den Leuten los ist,
kann ich langsam nicht mehr nachvollziehen.
Ja.
Erzielt sich vollkommen
in meinem Brain.
Wie das funktioniert.
Kannst du ein bestimmtes
WLAN-Heizungsthermostat empfehlen?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage,
Doktor Pronoupx.
Exzellent.
Ähm, ich würde dir gar keinen
WLAN-Thermostat empfehlen, weil
WLAN-Geräte meistens nicht, sondern nicht
Stromsparend sind.
Das heißt, dass man
laufend die Batterien wechseln muss.
Also ich würde dir was anderes empfehlen.
Ich mein, ich gehe mal davon aus,
du meinst nicht WLAN,
also wirklich WIFI.
Wahrscheinlich meinst du einfach Sachen, die halt
kein Kabel brauchen.
Und da kann ich dir zumindest
die Technik empfehlen, was ich dir ans Herz
legen würde. Und zwar, also
wohlgemerkt, das ist keine Empfehlung jetzt
für dieses Thermostat. Ich hab mir zum Testen das da
gekauft. Allerdings
kauft ihr das nicht. Nämlich erstens
ist es zu teuer. Bei Aliexpress
nur glaube ich 21 Euro.
Und ich finde die Qualität nicht
sonderlich gut.
Es könnte aber auch sein, weil ich zwischendurch einmal hingeschmissen habe
aus Versehen.
Ähm, zumindest
habe ich mir das letzte,
diese Woche, letzte Woche, diese
Woche, egal wann, diese Woche
bestellt
zum Ausprobieren
und zwar, um Zigbee auszuprobieren.
Es gibt zwei
relevante
Protokolle für so
Ultra Low Power Geräte.
Das ist einmal
Z-Wave und das ist Zigbee.
Die Geräte halten teilweise
2-3 Jahre, wohingegen die meisten
WLAN Geräte nicht länger als 6 Monate halten.
Also wahrscheinlich
willst du eher was auf Zigbee oder auf
Z-Wave Basis haben.
Ich hab das hier jetzt gekauft. Es funktioniert
wirklich gut, aber ich habe es noch nicht
großartig ausprobiert. Was ich ausprobiert habe
ist halt eine Automatisierung, dass das
um
19 Uhr im
Wohnzimmer die Heizung anmacht und um
22 Uhr im Wohnzimmer die Heizung ausmacht.
Es war so eine Testsache. Funktioniert wunderbar.
Aber wie gesagt, ich kann da keine großartige
Empfehlung für aussprechen, aber du willst
wahrscheinlich kein WLAN, sondern du willst Zigbee oder
Z-Wave haben.
Wobei ich gerade im Chat sehe, dass jemand ein
WLAN System hat, was 2 Jahre hält. Das ist
wirklich ungewöhnlich
für WLAN Sachen.
Valentin, was habt ihr da?
Was habt ihr für einen WLAN
Thermostat, was 2 Jahre hält?
Was Max System? Was ist denn Max System?
Das hat nichts mit mir zu tun, denke ich mal.
Ah, HomeMatic.
Ja Moment, HomeMatic ist wieder was anderes.
HomeMatic ist auch kein WLAN.
HomeMatic ist auch so ein
Special
Protokoll.
HomeMatic ist kein WLAN.
Da treffen ähnliche Sachen zu, wie
was ich für Zig, was ich auf,
was ich mit Zigbee und Z-Wave gesagt habe.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich meine nicht 2 Jahre Lebenszeit.
Ich meine 2 Jahre Batterie.
Also Batterie, Austauschzeit.
Also die meisten
WLAN Produkte, die es so gibt, auch an
Sensoren und sowas, die halten halt
kürzer als diese Z-Wave und Zigbee Sachen.
Ja, aber 2,
wie gesagt, 2 Jahre sollte das,
sollten es schon sein.
Weil ansonsten bist du ja
laufend damit beschäftigt. Die Dinger werden ja nicht
zeitgleich leer, ne. Also sprich,
wenn du alles halbe Jahr austauschen musst
und die Dinger nicht exakt
gleichzeitig ausgebaut hast,
dann ist das schon ein bisschen
schwierig.
Ja, aber 2, wie gesagt, 2 Jahre sollte das,
sollten es schon sein,
weil ansonsten bist du ja laufend damit beschäftigt.
Wenn du die Dinger nicht exakt gleichzeitig ausgebaut hast,
eingebaut hast,
dann bist du ja alle paar Wochen unterwegs
und tauscht irgendwo. Das ist kacke.
Also 2 Jahre muss das halten.
Das ist für mich auch das Minimum.
Und ich habe mir ja vor einer ganzen Weile
diese
Bali Express, als die mal
so ein Angebot hatten für Tür-
und Fenstersensoren, dass man erkennt,
welche Fenster auf und zu sind, habe ich mir vor einer ganzen
Weile mal die hier gekauft.
Allerdings nicht
zu dem Preis. Ich habe die für ungefähr 11 Dollar
das Stück bekommen, was wirklich
ziemlich günstig war
zum damaligen Zeitpunkt.
Und die habe ich jetzt glaube 3 Jahre
und die Batterie geht immer noch.
Also da bin ich echt
begeistert von. Übrigens, das
Bild hier ist Fake News,
denn
die Batterien, die die hier zeigen,
sind da gar nicht drinne.
Ich wollte nämlich die Batterien wechseln,
von diesen Dingern hier, und habe
mir einen 12er Pack
CR14250
gekauft, die übrigens
auch unter 1,5 AA
laufen. Es gibt ja Batterienbezeichnungen,
ist fast so schlimm wie USB-Standards.
Habe ich mir gekauft,
dann habe ich meinen Thermostat aufgemacht. Ich habe exakt
dieses Thermostat hier, nicht
was labe ich denn Thermostat, exakt diesen
Fenster-Türsensor, mache ich
auf, und es ist eine CR2-Batterie
drin.
Eine ganz andere Batterie, als
hier im
Bild drauf ist.
Keine Ahnung, was
die da agibaten wollen.
Vielleicht haben die das mal geändert.
Wie gesagt, meine ist nun 3 Jahre alt,
und jetzt habe ich mir halt noch ein paar Amazon
Basics bestellt dafür.
Ja,
so, das war eine Sache, die ich mir bestellt
habe. Was habe ich mir noch bestellt? Zeig mal her.
Ja, Walvertier, glaube ich dir,
passt ja. Ist doch gut, weil das zu
2 Jahre ist top.
Ich hatte das Problem
mit, ich habe mir auch überlegt, ob ich nicht
ganz am Anfang, als ich mir um diese Smart Home-Geschichte
ein bisschen Gedanken gemacht habe,
warum mir Home-Matic nicht so gefallen hat,
war die Integration
mit
Hubs, die nicht der offizielle
Home-Matic Hub oder Home-Matic
Stick oder was auch immer
ist, war schwierig zum damaligen
Zeitpunkt und es
war nicht so verbreitet.
Nicht so verbreitet heißt ja
manchmal, das Zeug ist über Morgendad
und es gibt viel weniger
Guides und Sachen, wo du gucken kannst.
Und mir ist halt wichtig, dass ich das in
meine Heimautomatisierung einbinden kann,
die halt auch schon zig andere Geräte
steuert.
Aber das mit, es ist Morgendad
hat sich nicht bewahrheitet, weil das
gibt es heute immer noch. Und es gibt
auch genug Geräte für.
Genau, was habe ich noch bestellt? Zeig mal.
Genau, wie gesagt, die Steckdose habe ich euch ja schon
gezeigt hier. Dann
das Baustellenlicht.
Dann habe ich mir noch einen Zigbee-Sensor
bestellt für Temperatur, Luft,
Feuchtigkeit, Luftdruck.
Ist jetzt nicht so interessant.
Genau, ein paar Batterien in den Stick.
Thermostat.
Dann habe ich mir noch so einen Bosch, weil es gab
ganz schön viele.
Es gab ziemlich viele.
Nicht den da. Es gab ziemlich viele
Boschgeräte im Angebot bei dem Prime.
So ein Entfernungsmesser
kann man auch mal gebrauchen. Warum nicht?
Besser haben,
als brauchen.
So, was hatten wir noch?
Bin so doof.
Warum mache ich immer Amazon zu dazwischen?
Ach ja.
Eine Flasche
Hochdruck. Nee, nicht Hochdruckreiniger.
Druckluft.
Puste, Pusteflasche. So wie nennt
man das? So eine Flasche, wo man beispielsweise
Tastaturentrags auspusten kann.
Luftdruckreiniger
oder so.
Heute und Morgen ist Cold War
PC Open Beta schon gespielt.
Nö. Echt?
Das schon.
Nee, 17 da.
17 da.
Ja, ich hab
nur auf den Chat geantwortet, der
gemeint hat, heute wäre Open.
Nee, aber das gucke ich mir mal an.
17 ist glaube ich sogar Samstag oder so.
Das werde ich mir dann mal
zu Gemüte führen.
Aber wahrscheinlich reg ich mich instant
auf und hab dann keinen Bock mehr.
Das kann auch gut sein.
Ja, Leute.
Und ich hab mir mal wieder
ähm
ich hab mir mal wieder eine SSD bestellt.
Weil ihr kennt ja so meine Standard
WTF
SSDs kann man nie genug
haben. Und ich hab das mal
zum Anlass genommen.
Die Festplatte
in meinem Fernsehrecorder.
Also in meinem
dem wir zusammen im Stream zusammengebaut haben.
Zu ersetzen durch eine 2TB SSD
für 100. Das war wirklich viel billiger.
Die hat glaube ich nur 150 Euro gekostet
beim Prime Day.
Ich hab doch so einen
Oh, ich hab doch so einen Teil hier
mit Festplatte drinne gehabt.
Mit TV Headend
und einem Dual Tuner
USB Kabel
TV Stick.
Zum Fernsehsachen aufnehmen.
Und da war halt noch so eine
Olle WD Green 2TB
HDD drinne.
So eine richtig oldschool Magnet Festplatte.
Die dann auch immer ein bisschen angelaufen ist.
Und du hast dann erstmal im Kodi gedrückt
ja hier mach an und dann hat er erstmal 5 Sekunden
Timeout weil die Festplatte noch anläuft.
Aber ich hab mir gedacht, weißt du was?
Das umgehen wir jetzt einfach indem wir da
eine SSD reinstecken und gut ist.
Also
ob es auch mal sinnlos 150 Euro
in Sand oder in Wind
geschossen wird da
für 2 Sekunden schnelleres
Bild auf My Media Center.
Aber der Preis dafür war beim Amazon
Prime Day, das war wirklich mal eine Sache, die echt okay war.
Ich glaube es hat 150,
155 Euro oder sowas gekostet.
Das hat sich wirklich gelohnt im Vergleich
zu normalen. Aber das heißt
gelohnt ist das falsche Wort.
Weil wer die Kohle
nicht ausgibt, der hat die Kohle noch. Also gelohnt
in dem Sinn kann man da eh nicht sagen,
man hat am Ende immer weniger
Geld als vorher.
Das ist auch das was ich mir immer denke bei
diesen ganzen Videos.
Hier komm in die WhatsApp Gruppe, hier ich mach jetzt
50 Milliarden im Monat, sonst wie
so ich zeig dir wie du reich wirst.
Es ist ganz einfach
reich zu werden Leute. Und es ist ganz einfach
Geld zu bekommen.
Man muss einfach nur mehr Geld behalten als
Geld ausgeben.
Big Prane
5 Cent
gutefrage.de
Tipps
Einfach mehr Geld behalten als ausgeben.
Und Stonks, genau.
Warte mal, gab es noch
irgendwas?
Ich glaube aber das war es.
Was ich gekauft habe.
Ach ne, ich habe mir
endlich, das haben wir
aber schon zuletzt uns im Stream angeschaut.
Ich habe mir endlich meine Vera
eine Vera
Imbo Schlösser gekauft.
Hier. Die wollte ich mir
schon eine Weile holen.
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht ey wenn Prime Day ist
und du so viel anderes bestellst kannst du
den jetzt auch endlich mal mitbestellen.
Die wollte ich mir schon lange holen.
Ah jetzt
ist soweit. Man kann jetzt sagen okay
ich glaube das hier
ich glaube das ist das gleiche aber hier das
ist das Angebots Set.
Ach ne, das hier ist das
reguläre, das hier ist das reguläre.
Das andere ist eben so ein special Ding, braucht
kein Mensch.
Man kann jetzt sagen okay
22 Euro für
so ein Schlüsselset
ist eigentlich ganz schön viel.
Da kriegste beim Aldi schon einen halben Werkzeugkasten für.
Stimmt, aber das
Vera Zeug, ich bin ja so ein kleiner
Vera Fanboy was Werkzeug
angeht und unknippe ich es bei
Zangen, okay.
Aber das
Zeug macht Spaß damit zu arbeiten.
Und was gibt es
besseres Leute?
Als wenn jetzt die Türe mal wieder klemmt.
Und man
die Tür ein bisschen einstellen muss.
Wir haben hier so eine Sicherheitstür
und wenn die nicht genau
fittet
Alter was ein Satz.
Also Leute, wenn die Tür
nicht genau fittet, was ich meine
ist, wenn die Tür nicht genau passt
in die Schlitze
dafür, dann
geht die nicht mal richtig zu.
Und die kann man auf
der einen Seite ein bisschen hochdrehen
und wenn die sich verzogen hat, dann gehts wieder.
Und was gibt es besseres? Zu sagen
Mist, die Tür klemmt.
Ich weiß schon genau was ich brauche.
Ich gehe hoch
an meinen
Werkzeugschrank, Schublade
auf, Immo Schlüsselsatz rausgeholt
an die Tür, Schraub
Schraub, Tür passt wieder,
zusammengesteckt, hochgebracht.
Wenn man schon vorher weiß, was man braucht,
wenn man weiß, wo es ist, das holt,
macht, es funktioniert, gibt
nix besseres. So deswegen wollte
ich mir schon ordentlich, wie gesagt, wollte ich mir
schon bestimmt ein halbes Jahr
kaufen. Hab ich mir gedacht, können wir
mal ein Primeplay jetzt mal machen.
LukiTrox
Ich auch, ich auch.
Er schreibt also heute den Antwort auf den
Chinesen Tweet gelesen, dann hat er Brain Cells verloren.
Ich auch. Aber mittlerweile
ist das so schlimm.
Jeder sieht, also
ne, das stimmt nicht, nicht jeder. Einige.
Die sind bloß laut.
Und nervig, vor allem
auf Twitter. Einige
sehen mittlerweile wirklich
und es ist nicht, es ist tatsächlich nicht
nur Twitter Deutschland, das ist ein allgemeiner Trend,
aber Deutschland ist da schon vorne mit dabei.
In den USA geht es aber auch richtig, richtig krass ab.
Die sehen wirklich
in jeglicher Aussage
irgendwas rassistisches
oder moralisch
oder wehrpflichtiges. In jeder.
Und auch wenn einfach einer nur dummes
Zeug labert, ohne
jetzt irgendwie mit dem Hinblick
drauf, er möchte jetzt Leute eine gewisse Gruppe
fertig machen und so. Einfach
man, man sehen so viele
Leute heute überall
wie soll man sagen, Gespenster irgendwie.
So nach dem Motto, oh das muss rassistisch
gemeint sein, oh das ist sexistisch, oh das ist
das ist irgendwie diskriminierend gemeint. Sonst wie
dabei haben die Leute einfach nur dummes
Zeug gelabert, ja. Man kann natürlich
auch, wenn man dummes Zeug labert,
Sachen sagen, die
manche Gruppen jetzt nicht so gut
auffassen, ja. Ich sage nicht, man sollte
einfach wild Leute beleidigen, man
sagen, ich rede mich raus mit, ich habe
doofes Zeug gelabert. Aber man muss nicht
immer vom Schlimmsten ausgehen
und jedem
direkt unterstellen, das wäre
irgendwie was voll Verwerfliches, was er gepostet hat.
Wo sind wir denn?
Das fördert doch jetzt wirklich,
das fördert doch beim besten Willen nicht, dass
man über Probleme spricht, das fördert
nur, dass sich keiner mehr traut, irgendwie
was zu sagen, weil er gleich
Bedenken haben muss,
dass er im schlimmsten Fall morgens gefeuert
wird, weil irgendeiner auf Twitter beim
Arbeitgeber angerufen hat, er würde hier
irgendwelche sexistischen Tweets oder so
verbreiten. Und es ist ja nichts, was ich mir
ausgedacht habe.
Das passiert
ja wirklich,
dass Leute auf Twitter
Sachen lesen, die
jemand gepostet hat, die man
eventuell irgendwie einer in ihrer
Welt gültigen Moralkodex
nicht
passend empfindet, dann suchen
die Leute den Arbeitgeber raus,
rufen beim Arbeit- das ist kein Witz,
es wäre
gut, wenn es ein Witz wäre, dann suchen die Leute
raus, wo der Typ arbeitet anhand seiner Tweets,
rufen beim Arbeitgeber an
und sagen, ihr Mitarbeiter ist
Nazi oder sowas.
Sind die eigentlich alle noch wirklich
von allen guten Geistern verlassen?
Man muss nicht alles
gut finden. Ich habe
sicherlich auch schon mal die ein oder anderen
Sachen gesagt, wo sich Leute zu Recht
dran gestört haben, weil ich einfach
nicht nachgedacht und blödes Zeug erzählt habe.
Okay. Aber man muss nicht immer
gleich vom Schlimmsten ausgehen, dass
wenn jemand was erzählt, dass das quasi
systematisch
äh,
diskriminierend gemeint wäre.
Sondern
manche Leute sagen einfach dummes Zeug
und vieles davon
ist noch nicht mal
noch nicht mal schlimm.
Vieles wird einfach
aufgebauscht extrem, weil man
zig Sachen reininterpretiert.
Man kann in die meisten Sätze was
reininterpretieren, aber bei den meisten ist das
garantiert nicht so gemeint.
Naja, gut. Ich habe keinen Bock.
Das Thema geht mir auf den Sack und weil mir das
Thema auf den Sack geht, habe ich Folgendes gemacht.
Ich bin auf Twitter gegangen und, achso,
das geht ja hier gar nicht jetzt.
Ich bin auf Twitter gegangen und habe
meinen Ort auf Andorra umgestellt.
So.
Und seit ich
meinen Ort auf Andorra umgestellt
habe, auf Twitter ist es viel entspannter.
Also wie machst du das doch mal konkret?
Zum Beispiel den Tweet, den ich vorhin gepostet
habe. Allein schon, dass man auf die
Idee kommt, da wieder irgendwie
rein zu interpretieren, das wäre jetzt irgendwie
diskriminierend irgendwelchen
Chinesen gegenüber. Meine Güte!
Und gerade auf Twitter Deutschland
ist es wirklich ätzend, ne?
Da sagt irgendwo einer was
in irgendeiner Fernsehshow
und ich rede jetzt nicht von den
durchgeknallten Typen da, also ich meine
jetzt nicht den veganen Koch
und Xavier Naidoo und sonst was,
die ja wirklich übelst einen an der Klatsche haben.
Sondern sagt mal einer irgendwas,
was du auch nur mit
im Entferntesten missverstehen könntest,
BÄM! Regen sich alle klar
übelst auf!
Was auch immer da los ist.
Deswegen konsumiere ich die ganzen Kram auch gar nicht mehr.
Der Wendler
ist jetzt auch
ist jetzt ja auch
was hat er erzählt?
Ich hab's nur am Rande verfolgt.
Was hat er erzählt?
Die Bundesregierung
irgendwas
Begeht Verbrechen an der Bevölkerung
oder irgendwie so komisches Zeug.
Also, die haben wirklich
einen Dachschaden mittlerweile.
Viele.
Also fühlst du dich gerade angegriffen
und musst apprenten?
Naja.
Warum nicht?
Wer sagt,
dass ich das nicht auch darf?
Also, wenn schon wegen so
ne Bullshit jeder da immer sich gleich angepisst
fühlt, da kann man sich ja auch mal
über den Bullshit
des Bullshits aufregen.
Also quasi Counterflame.
Generell muss ich ja auch mal sagen,
ich finde das an sich,
dass da sich Leute
über Sachen beschweren,
finde ich nicht schlimm.
Also, ich bin am einen
und man könnte sich über viel mehr
ernste Themen,
also ich fände es gut, wenn sich über mehr ernste Themen
auch ausgetauscht wird.
Ja.
Ohne dass jetzt irgendwie einer da bedenken
muss, dass er morgen seinen Job verliert.
Fänd ich nicht schlecht.
Was mich aber gerade auf Twitter
nervt, ist
dieses
sich gegenseitig
bestätigen. Das geht mir auf Twitter
auf den Sack. Also, die Leute
gehen nicht auf Twitter, weil sie da wirklich
ernsthaft
was
irgendwie was sagen wollen, eigentlich
gehen die Leute nur auf Twitter, dass sie sich
untereinander bestätigen können,
dass ihre Weltanschauung die moralisch
richtige, überlegene und beste ist.
Deswegen gehen die
meisten Leute mittlerweile irgendwie auf Twitter.
So, und dann hast du das Problem, dass du
was weiß ich, 50 Krüppchen
hast, die sich den ganzen Tag untereinander
recht geben. Ab und zu mal ein bisschen über
die Grenzen hinweg wird geflamt.
Aber eigentlich hast du
nur ganz viele Krüppchen, die sich untereinander recht
geben. Das ist gerade so auf Twitter.
Und die suchen dann auch den ganzen Tag
danach, wo hat einer vielleicht was
Anstößiges geschrieben. Und
eine Sache, die mir daraus auf den Sack
geht, ist dann, wenn so
unsinnige Shitstorms entstehen.
Wie gesagt, ich bin immer dafür, wenn einer
sagt, ja, das ist meine Meinung und so und so
ist das. Dafür sollte keinem
irgendwie
quasi soziale Verachtung
zu Teil werden.
Aber diese unsinnigen Shitstorms,
die sich dann formen, von Leuten,
die schon gehört haben, von ich hab
gehört, die eigentlich gar keine Ahnung mehr haben,
um was es eigentlich ursprünglich gegangen ist,
von der eigentlichen Thematik schon mal erst recht keine
Ahnung haben. Und sich dann zu
hunderten aufmachen, weil irgendwo irgendeiner
was weiß ich,
einen falschen Schriftzug auf dem
Schild hat, den falschen Namen
an seiner, was hatten wir letztens, Apotheke
hat, weil irgendwie
was was, auch wenn ich kein Fan von der
Schöneberger bin, sie hat letztens auch irgendwie was
über, ich glaub, was war es über dicke Leute oder so gesagt.
Oder, oder, nee, nee, was anderes.
Aber letztens hat auch irgend einer was über dicke
Leute erzählt, wo ich mir gedacht hab, ey fand
ich eigentlich ganz, ganz, ganz lustig. Ja, ich meine
ihr wisst, ich bin selbst nicht der Dünste.
Ist eigentlich ganz lustig gewesen. Und da drauf
wurde ich wieder aufgeregt. Body Shaming,
was ist hier los? Wie kann man sowas
nur senden? What the fuck?
Sollen sich alle mal wieder beruhigen?
Ach, die Schöneberger waren was mit Männern
und Make-up, genau.
Also es ist so
abgedreht
mittlerweile.
Es ist, es ist, es ist, es ist
echt wir einfach nur.
Es ist, es ist, es ist echt
wir einfach nur.
Also es ist
echt...
Also Twitter lesen macht echt keinen Spaß mehr.
Ich lese, was die Leute antworten, ich lese
die paar, die ich followe. Ich hab früher gerne
Twitter Trends gelesen, einfach weil man immer schnell
so was los ist und was hier...
Aber aktuell geht's mir echt auf den Sack.
Immer mehr Technik orientiert.
Na gut, Technik orientiert ist für mich ja nicht
verkehrt.
Ich bin einfach der Meinung,
man sollte bei den meisten Sachen mal die Kirsche
im Dorf lassen und nicht irgendwie gleich
den Weltuntergang herbeireden.
Ich glaub, das trifft's eigentlich ganz gut.
Weil es wird
einfach maßlos an allen Fronten
übertrieben.
Und auch wenn ich überhaupt nicht
gläubig bin, was das angeht,
so ein bisschen...
Weiß ich, ob man das Nächstenliebe
nennen sollte oder
so ein bisschen
versuchen zumindest
so ein bisschen Einfühlvermögen
zu zeigen
ist glaube ich nicht
verkehrt.
Das macht die Welt für alle besser.
Wenn man nicht immer gleich vom Schlimmsten ausgeht.
Ja, MikeCanFly
Verschwörungstheorie, Leute.
Aber das ist... Verschwörungstheorien
ist auch so was.
Ich finde, man sollte nicht alles, was
erstmal pauschal nicht mainstream
ist, sagen, es ist eine Verschwörungstheorie.
Weil Verschwörungstheorie ist auch aktuell
so ein Ding, mit dem
alles, was nicht gerade rassistisch
sexistisch diskriminierend
sonst was ist und man nicht drüber reden
möchte, ist Verschwörungstheorie.
Es gibt natürlich Sachen, da
muss man nicht drüber reden, wenn da einer ankommt mit Mondlandung
und Flat Earth und...
Meine Lieblings, also
meine persönliche Lieblingsverschwörungstheorie
ist
Obama
Body
Bodyguard
Rep
Reptile
Bodyguard
Nee
Ach, ich weiß nicht, wo es ist.
Es gibt eine Theorie, dass Obama
einen Bodyguard hatte, der Reptilienmensch war.
Also sowas ist natürlich total
bescheuert.
Aber um solche
Sachen geht es mir gar nicht.
Zum Beispiel, weil du gerade gesagt hast,
du willst mal was Konkretes wissen. Zum Beispiel
wollte man die letzten
paar Monate
über
was
nehmen wir konkret?
Zum Beispiel,
wenn man gesagt hat, ich sage nicht, dass ich das sage,
ich sage nur, wenn jemand das gesagt hatte,
wurde das oftmals als Verschwörungstheorie abgetan.
Wenn zum Beispiel einer gesagt hat,
er erkennt den Zusammenhang
zwischen
Maßnahmen, die getroffen wurden
für Corona
und den Auswirkungen, er erkennt da keinen
Zusammenhang.
Also da gibt es Leute, die haben sich vielleicht Statistik
angeguckt, wie wo was
infizierte und wie hat sich das entwickelt.
Und dann kam Maßnahmen und da hat sich das so entwickelt.
Und da gab es Leute, die haben gesagt,
ich erkenne da keinen Zusammenhang.
Und das ist eigentlich, finde ich, ein interessantes
Thema, wo sich mittlerweile auch ein paar Studien drum
gekümmert haben. Das ist eigentlich ein interessantes Thema,
wo man, dass es
wirklich wert wäre, darüber zu diskutieren,
weil daraus resultiert
ja auch, sind denn die Maßnahmen,
die getroffen werden, überhaupt sinnvoll
oder wäre es nicht sinnvoller was anderes zu machen.
Das ist ja eine Diskussion, die ist nicht unsinnig
zu führen. Problem war nur,
dass sowas instant mit
Aluhutverschwörungstheorie abgefackelt
wurde. Es ist doch
ein extremer Unterschied.
Ob jemand sagt, hey, ich erkenne den
Zusammenhang dazwischen nicht
oder ich bezweifle, dass Viren
existieren. Na, das eine ist einfach
nur Three-Head Low-Brain
und das andere ist, jemand,
der sich doch wirklich mit der Thematik beschäftigt hat
und für den es nicht ersichtlich
ist, wie das zusammenhängt. Es gibt ja sogar mittlerweile
Studien dazu, wo
habe ich letztens
auf YouTube ein Video dazu gesehen.
Wie heißt der Typ? Rika? Raika?
Der macht eigentlich ganz gute Sachen.
Professor, Spiele, Theorie.
Wie heißt denn der Typ auf YouTube?
Ja, der Typ.
Der hat letztens ein Video zugemacht.
Kann man sich ganz gut mal angucken.
Zu
Corona-Studien und Zusammenhang
zwischen
wo ist es denn?
Das könnte das Video hier gewesen sein,
wo er drei Studien
vorgestellt hat, wo es darum ging,
dass die sich angeschaut haben,
was wurden für Maßnahmen getroffen
und wie hat sich darauf
quasi die Zahl der Infizierten und sonst was geändert.
Und das sind ja Themen,
die wirklich
wichtig wäre,
darüber zu reden. Und wenn man
sowas dann abtut mit, ach nee,
da machen wir uns gar keine Gedanken drüber,
ist ja eh alles Verschwörungstheorie.
Das finde ich fatal unterm Strich, weil da ja auch
viele sinnvolle Sachen einfach untergehen.
Deswegen, ich finde, man sollte nicht zu
allem Verschwörungstheorie sagen, nur weil es einem vielleicht gerade nicht in Kram passt.
Aber ich gebe es insofern recht, weiß nicht, wie wir es geschrieben haben,
mit wirklich so Hardcore-Verschwörungstheorie
Leuten, die
wirklich davon überzeugt sind, dass
Obamas Bodyguard ein Reptilienmensch ist oder
die Erde flach ist oder was auch immer,
mit denen ist das äußerst
schwierig zu reden.
Aber es gibt übrigens
auch eine Studie zu,
dass Leute,
die von
etwas überzeugt sind,
wenn man denen
quasi,
nennen wir es mal, mehr oder weniger
unwiederlegbar
beweist,
dass
es nicht stimmt,
dass die Leute es danach nicht
einsehen, also dass die Leute das nicht
einsehen und danach,
obwohl du ihnen quasi gerade bewiesen hast,
dass es nicht stimmt, also
wasserdicht bewiesen hast, dass es nicht stimmt, was sie sagen,
sie sehen das nicht ein
und es ist nicht nur so,
dass die dann sagen, stimmt nicht,
sie glauben danach noch mehr
an das, was du ihnen gerade widerlegt hast.
Jetzt auch Studien zu,
ist eigentlich
erst mal abstrus,
aber ich glaube, das liegt zum größten Teil
daran, dass
Leute ein riesengroßes Problem haben,
sich einzugestehen, wenn sie
falsch liegen.
Für manche Leute
grenzt das an totalem
Gesichtsverlust und totales
irgendwie
zerstörtes Selbstwertgefühl
irgendwie, wenn sie
falsch liegen.
Ja,
was aus meiner Sicht eigentlich ziemlich
ziemlich bescheuert ist, weil
wir hätten, glaube ich,
die Großzahl,
also unsere Welt würde heute definitiv
anders sehen, anders aussehen,
wenn sich immer nur die
quasi immer die Sache durchgesetzt hätte,
die zuerst da war, so nach dem Motto.
Also sprich, so ist es, so bleibt es
und gibt nichts anderes.
Deswegen finde ich es auch gerade
im
wissenschaftlichen Umfeld
ein bisschen merkwürdig,
wenn es
Leute gibt,
die, also dort läuft es ja so,
sprich, wenn du
irgendwie
was findest, was halt nicht passt
zu der aktuellen Sache, dann ist halt
unsere aktuelle Weltanschauung nicht ganz komplett.
Aber dass
gerade dort
viele, viele, viele
Leute, und das kommt wirklich so auch aus
dieser Verschwörungstheorie-Ecke, viele
Leute, die den Wissenschaftlern irgendwie in
schräg draus Themen drehen wollen, finde ich
merkwürdig. Da wird dann zum Beispiel behauptet,
so nach dem Motto, ja,
Theorie XY
hat sich jetzt ja als falsch
rausgestellt, warum sollte ich denn das
aktuelle glauben?
Die Frage ist eigentlich vollkommen falsch
gestellt.
Da geht es weniger
ums Glauben,
darum,
das bildet halt unsere aktuelle Realität
am widerspruchsfreiesten ab.
Ich glaube, niemand wird ernsthaft
behaupten, er hat hier auf seinem Zettel
exakt stehen, wie die Welt funktioniert.
Wie auch, wie soll er das dann machen?
Wir haben immer nur
Annäherungsversuche,
die mehr oder weniger gut an die
Realität rankommen.
Und manche Sachen sind halt nicht ganz vollständig.
Aber muss man nun wirklich sagen,
in den letzten
drei,
vierhundert Jahren hat man doch schon
ziemlich gute Sachen sich überlegt.
Ich meine, guck mal, man konnte
hier auf der Erde
Dinge ausrechnen, dass man es
geschafft, also ausrechnen und bauen
und planen, dass man es
geschafft hat, von hier zu irgendeinem
Asteroid zu fliegen.
Also, ganz so fern
ab von der Realität kann das ja
nicht sein.
Zumal, dass dann alle, die
sagen, hier Wissenschaft blöd
sind, auch nicht besser.
Sie haben ja nichts, was diese Sache besser
könnte oder besser erklären
würde.
Das ist genauso.
Ich kann mir jetzt
irgendwie was ausdenken.
Okay.
Das ist ich.
Ich werde gerade
irgendwas sagen. Genau.
Ich könnte jetzt zum Beispiel sagen,
der Zug fährt morgens nur auf
die Arbeit, weil es den Berg runtergeht.
Könnte sein.
Wäre ja möglich. Vielleicht geht es ja
permanent den Berg runter
von mir.
Ich könnte sagen,
Elektrizität und sowas gibt es alles
gar nicht. Aber dann sagt einer
zu mir, Max, du fährst doch morgens mit dem Zug
zur Arbeit. Dann sage ich, ja, natürlich.
Aber es geht ja auch bis nach Frankfurt
von Hanau aus den Berg runter.
Dann ist dann halt die nächste Frage,
wie fährt denn der Zug mittags wieder
zurück?
Und da wird es dann natürlich schon schwierig.
Ich glaube, keiner
wird ernsthaft behaupten. Er weiß wirklich,
wie die Welt funktioniert. Aber es gibt halt
schon ganz gute Annäherungsversuche.
Und dann zu sagen, ey, ich habe da eine
alternative Theorie, die
nur einen absoluten
Bruchteil
dessen sinnvoll erklären kann,
was die anderen erklären können,
ist irgendwie nicht so sinnvoll.
Wird von Pferden gezogen. Kann alles sein.
Da wirst du einfach, wo sind sie?
In der Lok vielleicht.
Die Menschheit lernt
ja zum Glück, auch wenn ich da aktuell
ein bisschen Zweifel habe, aber ich glaube,
auf lange Sicht betrachtet ist das so,
lernt ja kontinuierlich dazu. Und in der
heutigen Zeit eigentlich mehr als denn je.
Wenn man sich guckt, was für bahnbrechende
Sachen die letzten 300, 400 Jahre erfunden wurden
und was wir eigentlich alles gemacht haben,
sieht man so
verkehrt, so verkehrt
kann das Ganze nicht sein.
Streamst du eigentlich die nächsten Tage die Crottbeter? Ja, wahrscheinlich schon.
Und man hat ja öfters
mal falsch gelegen. Und es war zum
damaligen Zeitpunkt halt irgendwie
so Stand der
Technik, Stand der Wissenschaft.
Wusstet ihr, dass man vor noch nicht allzu
langer Zeit davon ausging,
dass Babys, frisch das
geborene Babys keine Schmerzen empfinden
und darauf hin wurden dann solche Sachen
wie Beschneidung und was auch immer
ohne Betäubung durchgeführt, weil man
sich zur damaligen Zeit sicher war, Babys
empfinden keine Schmerzen. Heute weiß man natürlich
totaler Schwachsinn. Aber
wichtig ist, dass man daraus lernt.
Und ich glaube, auf lange Sicht gesehen
macht das die Menschheit noch.
Aus ihren Sachen lernen.
Manchmal hast du
halt so das Gefühl, es geht rückwärts,
wo ich mir halt so denke,
muss das sein?
Gerade, gerade, gerade
okay,
ich bin gleich, ich bin gleich ruhig
mit dem Thema, ja. Aber gerade
die Sachen mit
dass man manche Sachen nicht mehr diskutieren
sollte oder darf, ohne dass man Angst
haben muss um seinen Job und sowas,
finde ich nicht gut.
Weil ich bin der Ansicht
und ich denke mal, da hätten wir jetzt
irgendwie einen Historiker oder so am
Start, der wird mir da Recht geben.
Die Menschheit ist nur da, wo sie heute ist,
weil sie miteinander geredet hat.
Weil nur
weil die Menschen miteinander reden können
und recht sozial sind,
konnten
Sachen, die, was weiß ich, an Ort
A erfunden wurden, 2000
Kilometer woanders
das gleiche machen,
ohne es neu erfinden zu müssen.
Das heißt, hätten die Menschen nicht miteinander
reden können, oder noch viel
einfacher gesagt, ja, der Opa hat was
erfunden und der Enkel konnte es dann
die nächsten zwei Generationen auch
wieder, oder noch verbessern und nochmal weitergeben.
Hätten wir nicht miteinander reden können, hätte das nicht
funktioniert.
Und das ist das, wo ich denke, okay, irgendwie
verlieren wir das gerade, miteinander zu reden
über wichtige Dinge.
Können wir allerdings schneller als
die Klimakatastrophe verlieren? Ja, das wird sich
zeigen. Das ist auch so ein Ding,
wo ich das Gefühl habe,
dass das
auf kurze Sicht nicht immer
stimmen muss, dass die Menschheit da
aus ihren Fehlern oder auf lange
Sicht lernt aus dem, was sie scheiße gebaut
hat.
Also die letzten 2000 Jahre hat man es gesehen, es
ging irgendwie vorwärts, ja, also da hat das
wohl gestimmt, aber aktuell
zumindest bei dieser Sache bin ich mir nicht so sicher,
ob die da draus, ob wir da
zumindest kurzfristig sogar draus gelernt
haben.
Es gibt da ja durchaus
kritikwürdige Punkte
bei der ganzen Klimageschichte.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen
würde ich ja mal zumindest behaupten, dass
der weit überwiegende Teil
zumindest in Deutschland eingesehen hat,
dass es sowas zumindest schon mal gibt.
Das wird nicht mehr bezweifelt.
Es gibt jetzt, also
das sah übrigens vor 10 Jahren noch ganz
anders aus, da haben viele Leute gesagt,
Klimawandel gibt es nicht, heute sind wir
ja schon ein bisschen weiter, da sagen die meisten,
ja, gibt es, aber der Mensch hat damit
wenig zu tun.
Und da sind wir jetzt wieder am Punkt,
da finde ich es dann wieder wichtig,
drüber zu diskutieren, okay,
wie kommt man da drauf, warum, weshalb und was
dafür und da wieder, was
sicherlich niemand, was
sicherlich
niemand,
was wollte ich jetzt sagen,
was sicherlich
keinem überzeugt, das wollte ich sagen, was sicherlich
keinem überzeugt ist, wenn sich da
jemand hinstellt und sagt, okay,
diese und diese
Klimadinger, das ist jetzt Fakt
und keinerlei
Diskussion erlaubt.
Das überzeugt keinen, der da irgendwelche
Zweifel dran hat.
Die Fakten haben wir seit den 90er Jahren,
Handlung ist daraus nicht wirklich, naja,
naja,
zumindest, zumindest nicht genug.
Also,
viele Leute haben heute schon
ein anderes Verständnis
von dieser Sache und
andere Einstellungen,
was Umweltschutz angeht, also
ich würde nicht sagen, dass da nichts passiert
ist, aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht genug passiert.
Ey, das ist auch so ein Ding.
Ja, das verstehe ich auch nicht so genau.
Warum, warum sich da viele, ich meine,
doch, eigentlich, eigentlich ist mir es klar,
warum viele Leute sich so dagegen wehren.
Man wehrt sich dagegen, weil
es jetzt schon absehbar ist, dass das
einschneidende
Umstrukturierung erfordert, geben wird, wie auch immer.
Ähm,
deswegen mag man das nicht.
Weiß Leute mögen das natürlich nicht.
Ich mag ja, ich mag es auch nicht, ja,
wenn ich, wenn einer zu mir sagt, Max, morgen
musst du nicht, musst du auf irgendeine Konferenz
mit 500 Leuten, die du nicht kennst, also ja,
da hab ich keinen Bock drauf, aber
die meisten Leute mögen das ja nicht, ja.
Wenn sich dann, wenn sich da was ändert.
Deswegen verstehe ich übrigens
auch nicht,
warum
es so wenig
Parteien, Politiker, wie auch immer, gibt,
die eine, eine, irgendwie eine
Zukunftsvision haben. Wo man,
der, der wirklich, wo wirklich mal sich einer
hinstellt und sagt, ey, so,
soll,
so soll es sein, 2050
und das
ist unser Plan.
Gibt's nicht, also
es gibt ja immer so Rumgewürste
von heute auf morgen, aber irgendwas
mit, irgendwas
mit Plan
vermisse ich da tatsächlich, ja.
Also jetzt nicht nur
ab und zu mal zum Zeitgeist
passende Sprüche
raushauen, sondern auch wirklich mal ganz
konkret sagen, okay, wie stellt man sich das vor
und was ist unser Plan
da hinzukommen, also wirklich konkret,
was dann für mich auch
zum Beispiel bedeuten würde, okay,
wie gedenkt man denn mit Problemen
umzugehen, ist ja nicht nur Klimawandel,
ist ja auch was, ich, Digitalisierung,
wenn du Leute hast, die arbeitslos werden, alles mögliche,
was in Zukunft auf uns zukommt, wie
gedenkt man damit umzugehen,
was ist dann zum Beispiel mit Zukunftstechnologien,
also mit Zukunftstechnologien
meine ich, by the way, kein
Internetausbau, Internetausbau ist
keine Zukunftstechnologie,
Internetaufbau ist eigentlich was, was jetzt
da sein muss, aber nicht ist, das
wissen wir ja alle. Moin Michael,
50 Billionen, Nico C.S., Dankeschön für den Sub,
ah nee, hast dem Krayt
Wilhelm einen geschenkt, exquisite, Dankeschön
für den Sub, huge.
Aber da gehört ja noch viel mehr dazu,
zum Beispiel eine Zukunftstechnologie
aus meiner Sicht wäre zum Beispiel,
wenn man jetzt weiß,
dass zum Beispiel
in China auch immer mehr
Leute immer besseren Lebensstandard
haben und Indien geht es jetzt auch ab
und dass auch immer mehr Inder
und Chinesen anfangen, ich nehme jetzt mal
die zwei als Beispiel, weil es relativ viele Leute sind,
jetzt anfangen immer mehr Fleisch zu
futtern,
da muss man sich natürlich zurechtfragen,
wo sollen das alles herkommen?
Wir können ja
keine Ahnung, Ziegen auf dem Mond
oder so, das wird ein bisschen schwierig.
Wo soll das herkommen? Zum Beispiel eine Sache,
die so im Anfangsstadium
ist, ist ja gerade, dass man sich
überlegt, okay, kann man Fleisch
nicht irgendwie herstellen,
also meine eine Variante wäre, alle werden Veganer,
das werden wir nicht hinkriegen, ich bin
auch kein Veganer, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen Bock,
Veganer zu werden, ich kann
übrigens die Argumente, warum das hier,
kann ich voll und ganz nachvollziehen,
also meine Sache, dass alle Veganer werden,
aber das ist recht unrealistisch.
Die nächste Frage ist, wo soll das
alles herkommen?
Und da gibt es jetzt ja die ersten Ansätze, dass man sagt,
okay, man versucht Fleisch
herzustellen, ohne dass man Tiere
braucht, was ja eigentlich ein ziemlich
guter Ansatz ist.
Also der Ansatz ist ja super.
Weil man sagt, okay, man muss
erst, das wird ja auch den Hauptkritikpunkt
von Veganer, erstmal
quasi,
ja,
ja, zunächst einmal nicht schlecht, ich will nicht sagen, dass was schlechtes
ist, wenn man Vegan ist, aber den gäbe
es dann nicht mehr, weil man müsste
keine Tiere mehr umbringen für Fleisch,
sondern da gibt es die ersten Ansätze, Versuche gibt
es ja schon, hast du schon mal Fleischersatz
mit Beyond Meatburger, habe ich schon gegessen, schmeckt
nicht schlecht.
So was von Scheiße,
künstlich, warum ist das Scheiße?
Wäre es besser,
jegliche, jegliche
Sachen für
Viehhaltung umzubauen?
Es geht übrigens bei dieser Geschichte
nicht um Fleischersatz,
es geht darüber, dass man
echtes, sagen wir mal,
Kuhmuskelfleisch
im Labor züchtet.
Das wäre so eine Technologie, wo ich sage, ja,
das ist, das ist
was Zukunftsträchtiges,
irgendwie, also du isst
dann kein kunstliches Fleisch,
du isst wirklich Schweinefleisch,
nur dass es halt nicht auf einem Schwein
gewachsen ist.
So, und das
würde das Problem lösen,
dass immer mehr Leute auf der Welt Fleisch
futtern würden,
das würde eine Vielzahl
von Problemen lösen, das würde sicherlich auch
was Methan, sonst was
Ausstoß, was bringen.
Du müsstest keine Tiere mehr umbringen, das ist das, was mir
ehrlich gesagt am wichtigsten ist an der ganzen Geschichte.
Aber das ist auch
so ein Ding, wo ich mich frage, okay,
warum haben wir
keinen, der sagt, okay,
solche Zukunftstechnologien, das
wäre was, wo man sich wirklich
Know-how aufbauen könnte,
dass man auch technologisch
in Deutschland in der Zukunft was hat,
was die Welt von einem will.
Und ob
diese Technologie jetzt
sinnvoll ist am Ende,
ob das sich, ob da
wirklich, ob das
serienreif mal wird
und ob das dann sich lohnt,
das muss man gucken.
Aber das kann man jetzt noch gar nicht sagen.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein Forschungsgebiet,
wo ich denke, dass das
sehr wichtig sein könnte in der Zukunft.
Gerade wenn Inder und Chinesen jetzt dazu kommen
und auch alle noch mehr Fleisch futtern.
Man darf nicht vergessen, dass gerade
in China und in Indien,
vor allem im asiatischen Raum,
da wurde
die letzten Jahrhunderte
sehr viel vegetarisch gefuttert.
Da war schon Fleisch dabei, aber sehr viel Gemüse.
Und da gibt es auch Statistiken zu.
Der Fleischkonsum gerade in den Ländern,
dort, wo es dir jetzt auch immer besser geht,
der steigt sprunghaft an.
Da muss man sich schon fragen,
wie willst du die Leute alle füttern?
Und eins kann ich euch sagen,
die Chinesen
werden da nicht sonderlich viele
ethische Skrupel haben,
Sachen zu machen,
wenn es die Leute ernährt.
Ja, darauf einfach
Frikadelle, genau.
Da kannst du schon mal von ausgehen, das wird dir
ziemlich egal sein.
Was, in Israel wird doch Fleisch
mit einem 3D-Drucker gedruckt.
Das habe ich auch irgendwo gelesen.
Zumindest, was ich damit sagen will,
ist,
das vermisse ich einfach,
dass wir Leute haben mit Zukunftsvisionen.
Ich muss den Sachen ja gar nicht
zustimmen und sagen,
so stelle ich es mir auch vor.
Aber ich fände es cool, wenn wir mal
Leute in der Politik hätten,
die wirklich Zukunftsvisionen haben
und auch einen Plan,
wie man sowas umsetzen kann.
Weil aktuell habe ich das Problem,
ich kann es euch jetzt ja sagen, was ich gewählt habe,
die letzten Wahlen,
ich habe alles ungültig gewählt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wen ich wählen soll.
Ich habe legit, das habe ich glaube ich schon mal erzählt,
ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, wen ich wählen soll.
Ich kann mich nicht dazu durchregen,
in irgendeinen zu wählen.
Ich finde alles so
einheitsprämäßig, vielleicht
bis auf ein paar Ausnahmen
an den jeweiligen Seiten.
Und planlos,
ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, wen ich wählen soll.
Klar, letztendlich,
mein Opa hat auch immer gesagt,
nach dem Motto, du hast die Stimme verschenkt.
Ja, ist so.
Ich würde noch besser als gar nicht wählen gehen.
Ich kann mich echt nicht,
ich weiß wirklich nicht,
wen ich wählen soll.
Die Partei, ja.
Die Partei habe ich glaube ich,
doch, das stimmt gar nicht als alles.
Ich glaube bei der letzten,
wo es um die letzte Europa-Geschichte ging,
habe ich glaube ich sogar die Partei gewählt.
Ich hatte die Auswahl, irgend sowas
der Richtung zu wählen oder ungültig zu wählen.
Deswegen habe ich wirklich keine Ahnung.
Und ich denke,
wenn man,
wenn man glaubt, dass,
an sich finde ich ja gerade,
was Umwelt-
und Tierschutz und so, das ist ja was,
was ich nicht abgeneigt bin.
Allerdings, das mein Problem, was ich habe,
mit zum Beispiel die Grünen zu wählen,
ist, zumindest ist das ein Eindruck,
der sich mir aufdrängt.
Die sind ja gerade auch voll im Hoch
und voll beliebt.
Ich habe den Eindruck,
dass die aktuelle Taktik ist,
man sagt,
man ist grün und ökologisch,
allerdings,
ohne,
dass man
den Leuten irgendwie die negativen Seiten
verkaufen,
verkauft. Also sprich,
man sagt,
wir machen alles super umweltfreundlich,
wir machen alles,
keine Ahnung, alles super grün,
aber es muss sich keiner
irgendwie einschränken. Das ist natürlich eine super
Taktik. Einschränken mag keiner.
Und viele
Leute sind halt eben, was Umweltschutz
und Klimawandel angeht, auch
zu begeistern.
Und das ist natürlich eine gute Taktik,
aber realistisch ist es nett.
Du kannst ja nicht sagen,
ja, du kriegst alles wie bisher und noch
Umweltschutz obendrauf.
Das ergibt doch
keinen Sinn. Und außerdem,
spätestens,
wenn die dabei sind, dass sie was
machen dürfen,
ist halt auch fraglich, ob sie was machen.
Weil in Hessen haben wir
seit ein paar Jahren schon einen grünen
Umweltminister oder sowas, ist er.
Und da ist nichts passiert.
Genau. Cooper sagt,
erstens, gegen den Kohleausstieg stimmt und
zweitens, eine riesen Sache,
wo sie damals mit angetreten sind, weiß ich
in Hessen noch.
Was ich persönlich nicht
gut fand,
aber womit sie angetreten sind, ist,
dass es quasi komplettes Nachtflugverbot
gibt am
Flughafen dann und dann
und keine Startbahn gebaut wird
und sonst was. Und wisst ihr, was gibt?
Kein richtiges Nachtflugverbot und eine neue
Startbahn. So.
Und da sind wir mit dem grünen Umweltminister.
Da denke ich mir auch so, okay,
man kann viel erzählen, wenn der Tag
lang ist. Ich fand die Idee damals nicht
sonderlich gut, weil Frankfurt mit,
das hemmt Frankfurt schon enorm,
wenn man den Flughafen nicht ausbaut, aber
okay, was ich damit sagen wollte,
es passt nicht zusammen, mit was erzählt wurde
und was gemacht wurde.
Ja, Umut, da hast du recht.
Wenn man sich
zwei Euro Kilogramm Hackfleisch
für, keine Ahnung, 50 Cent beim Lidl
kauft, da ist das so. Man kann aber auch
durchaus hier was Gescheites essen.
Machen die
meisten nicht, das stimmt. Ja.
Hast du den aktuellen
Rentenentwurf zum Urheberrecht gesehen?
Nee, ich weiß nur, dass die
Uploadfilter
und
solche Dinge, die wollen so und
Vorratsdaten sprechen, das wird dann immer um 5 Ecken doch
gemacht, wenn gerade wieder keiner drüber
redet.
Ja, so als haben wir es
immer ganz schön, ganz schön weit abgeschwiffen
vom eigentlichen Thema, aber ich habe
heute gesagt, heute ist Laber-Enspannungsstream.
Das soll übrigens
die japanische Aussprache
von Hitpipes sein. Die trifft
es nicht so ganz.
Bei der Playstation 5 Präsentation
haben die, haben sie erzählt, was für
was für Innereien die Playstation
5 hat und dann weiß der halt
der Typ da das aus.
Also die Japaner nehmen ja gerne englische
Wörter und machen ein O hinten dran.
Und da haben die Leute gesagt, Hitto
Pippo.
Ihr habt das versucht hier in Text, aber Text
to Speech kann es nicht.
Aber ich mag die
japanische Aussprache von so Wörtern.
Die sprechen das immer so, so
energisch betont und
zackig aus, die Japaner.
Ich finde das, ich finde Japanisch, ich
kann absolut, ich kann, verstehe kein Wort.
Aber ich, ich, ich höre Japanisch gerne.
Können ihr auch noch ein bisschen über C++?
Oh nee, hör mal auf, nein, nein, nein, wir waren doch
kein, wenn, wenn, also
wenn jetzt irgendjemand mit C++ anfängt,
bin ich noch eine Stunde mit C++ Rant
beschäftigt. Hast du schon das PS5
UI gesehen? Ich glaube kurz heute
auf Twitter, ja.
Ich glaube
heute kurz auf Twitter.
Ja, ich glaube, ich glaube den Startbildschirm habe ich
mal auf Twitter gesehen.
Nein, ich bin kein Weep, aber ich
höre gerne Japanisch.
Was, was eigentlich
gut zusammenpasst.
Aber ich gucke
eigentlich keine Anime, so gut wie keine.
So, also.
Nee, das habe ich heute auf Twitter gesehen.
Ich glaube, das war einfach das Thumbnail von
dem Video.
Okay, zeig mal, wie sieht das PS5
UI aus?
Okay, login.
Könnte auch, das sieht
als, das könnte auch von irgendeinem Android-Telefon sein.
Äh.
Ach, jetzt ist es
unten nicht mehr oben.
Ach, gut.
Es erinnert mich
echt ziemlich an ein Tablet
vom Layout her.
Hier oben das Ding, da unten
die Start-Buns.
Schon mal was mit Sunny Home Manager gemacht,
nee.
Oh, der Omote heute in
Rebellstimmung.
So, also, es gibt
irgendwelche Kacheln.
Und irgendein LittleBigPlanet
Hintergrund, oder was auch immer das ist.
Das wird doch nicht der Standard Hintergrund sein.
Ja.
Das ist das aktuell laufende Spiel.
Das sind was, irgendwelche Video
Captures, okay.
Okay, das ist jetzt.
Es sieht jetzt ehrlich gesagt
ein bisschen
minimalistisch aus
für meinen Geschmack.
Schwer zu sagen.
Okay.
Das ist wirklich das, was die gezeigt haben.
Das ist aber, da sieht man jetzt nicht viel.
Also, wie, was ist, wo
ist das Hauptmenü?
Hier.
Das da.
Hier ist das Hauptmenü.
Ja, das muss man erstmal in Aktion sehen.
Also, ich finde gerade, es ist ein bisschen
ein bisschen sehr minimalistisch.
Es ist ein bisschen, also
es ist nicht, es ist nicht ganz so, ganz so
das Switch, das Switch-Menü
ist ja quasi nicht existent.
Sowohl von den Funktionen her, als auch
vom Menü an sich. Also, die Switch hat
ja, hat ja quasi gar kein Menü.
Die hat ja wirklich nur das Nötigste,
was da sein muss,
damit man die minimalsten Sachen irgendwie machen
kann. So, und an Funktionen
fehlt der Switch eh an allen Ecken
und Enden. Ich meine, ich verstehe bis
heute nicht,
warum eine Switch als
mobile Konsole konzipiert, keinen
Browser hat. Verstehe ich einfach nicht.
Ich verstehe es aus Nintendo Sicht,
weil sie Schiss vor Exploits haben. Das ist mir auch klar.
Aber dann sollen sie sich
irgendwas Sandbox mit, irgendwas ausdenken.
Also, ein mobiles Gerät
ohne einen Browser ist halt
Paint's Champ.
Wozu?
Warum nicht? Sogar
wusste, dass der Nintendo
DS einen Browser hatte.
Wieso gab es zum Apple Event eigentlich keinen Stream von dir?
Wahrscheinlich weil ich mit anderen Sachen beschäftigt
war.
Gibt es eigentlich mittlerweile
Netflix und Gedöns
für Switch?
Das gab es ja eine ganze
Weile nicht. Ah ne.
Das ist auch so
ein Ding. Es ist ein bisschen
weh. Also, Switch ist von der Funktionalität
her doch schon Hardcore
minimalistisch.
So.
Das sieht mir auch
ziemlich minimalistisch aus.
Allerdings muss man das erste Mal wirklich in Aktion
dann sehen, wie sich das anfühlt.
Ach so was hier.
Das sieht doch jetzt wie ein ganz normales
Playstation Menü aus.
Nur, dass es immer mehr
Tablet-like aussieht. Jetzt mal
ernsthaft. Wenn euch jemand
sagen würde, das ist ein Screenshot von meinem
Tablet,
würde ich dem sofort glauben.
Oder das hier.
Könnte sofort von irgendeinem Tablet sein.
Instant. Aber das hier
sieht ziemlich klassisch Playstation-mäßig aus.
Oben hast du hier deine Buttons.
Unten hast du irgendwie
ganz viel Werbe
geschwurbelt, was eh kein Mensch interessiert.
Das Schlimmste, ich bin ja
mal gespannt. Ich habe mir das neue Menü
von der Xbox Series X dann angeguckt. Ne, Xbox.
Wie heißt das Ding jetzt?
Geh ich mal in die neue Xbox.
Pro,
kenne ich nicht.
Du musst nicht fünfmal posten.
Ich habe es schon gesehen. Hat ja sonst
keiner im Chat was geschrieben.
Also das Schlimmste,
das Schlimmste Menü hat immer
noch die Xbox One.
Also mittlerweile
geht es. Es ist immer noch scheiße.
Aber das Schlimmste Menü war die
Xbox One bei Release.
So ein Confuser-Kack
habe ich ja noch nie gesehen.
Oder was sage ich als Xbox Fanboy?
Also das war das Schlimmste,
was sie sich hätten ausdenken können.
Mittlerweile ist es besser, aber es ist immer noch kacke.
Ja, es sieht doch eigentlich
halt aus wie ein Playstation-Menü.
Es sieht benutzbar aus, ja.
Der Friseur hat mal
Der Friseur hat doch mal ein Video zum neuen Xbox gemacht.
Hat auch mal ein Video gemacht zum neuen Xbox.
Da sieht man auch das Menü ganz gut.
So und da sieht man
Kacke.
Feels Batman.
Xbox One ist aktuell Müll.
By the way
Der war da 25 oder so, ne?
Nee, nee, Quatsch.
Der war
29 damals.
Sieht der Fabian auf dem Bild
aus wie 29?
Nee, oder?
Moment, hier fängt das Menü an.
Das war so schlimm.
Das erste Xbox-Menü.
Alter, war das Scheiße.
Das war so
so ein Müll.
Das sieht aus wie Windows 8, ja, das ist ja das Schlimme da dran.
Ja, und hier zeigt er wie es auf
der Xbox 360 ausgesehen hat.
Das war cool. Ich muss euch
sagen, mein Herz schlägt immer noch
für die Xbox 360 was das angeht.
Das Beste ist ja, dass der Avatar
noch sogar so aussieht wie ich.
Mittlerweile habe ich ein bisschen weniger Haare
hier so neben, aber ansonsten sieht der Avatar
original aus wie ich.
Und den Puster.
Der Teile oder
Puster. Und der Karsten mit C.
Dann kommt jetzt so eine Kacke. Dieses
Drecks-Xbox-Menü, das
war so schlecht. Mittlerweile geht's ja.
Es ist ja, es ist immer noch kacke, aber
mittlerweile geht's.
Ja, ich muss jetzt mal kurz schauen,
ob ich irgendwas im Chat übersehen habe.
Gucken wir mal kurz hier, wo habe ich den Chat?
Ich muss auch gleich
pennen, morgen früh ist wieder Arbeit angesagt.
Aber Chat, guck mal nochmal schnell durch.
Was hab erst letztens herausgefunden, dass
Netflix eigentlich ziemlich viele Filme hat, aber es
Filme gibt, die in verschiedenen Ländern nicht sichtbar
sind. Ja.
Ja, ja.
Netflix hat ja auch kein
Interesse dran, die Leute zu bannen. Es ging da
mal Gerüchte rum, Netflix würde Leute bannen, aber
Netflix hat ja kein Interesse dran. Ich
habe mein Netflix-Abo übrigens wieder auslaufen
lassen, ich gucke so wenig normale Filme,
dass mir Amazon Prime reicht.
Also ich habe die Prime-Videos und kaufe mir da
manche Sachen. Übrigens, ich habe mal eine Frage.
Guckt einer von euch,
wir haben doch hier bestimmt
irgendwelche Star Trek-Fans.
Guckt einer von euch
das hier?
Habe ich nämlich gerade
die erste Staffel fertig geguckt auf Amazon
Prime?
Mega
geil, ey.
Ich bin da selten begeistert von irgendwelchen
Serien, aber ultra
nice. Also ich bin kein
großer Star Trek-Fan, muss ich sagen.
Also
viele Sachen, die da verarscht
werden, kenne ich gar nicht.
Aber mega geil, ey.
Das ist genau die richtige
Mischung aus
übertrieben lustig, an Stellen,
welche lustig sein soll. Und jede
Episode so voll gepackt
mit, mit
Zeug, dass
eigentlich von Anfang bis Ende laufen irgendwas ist.
Ich finde es richtig geil.
Wie heißt das ja?
The Orville, oder? The Orville.
Die Orville.
So, allerdings muss ich
sagen, ich habe jetzt die
ersten paar Folgen
von der zweiten Staffel schon
geguckt und die waren
ein bisschen lahm im Vergleich zur ersten Staffel.
Also lahm vom Erzähltempo her.
Weil ich interessiere mich
ehrlich gesagt jetzt nicht so sehr dafür,
wer auf einem Raumschiff was mit wem
hat und so, außer es ist lustig gemacht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch besser wird.
Also die erste Staffel fand ich bisher deutlich
deutlich besser.
So, also Chat, habe ich was übersehen.
Hast du Expans
geschaut? Ja, aber nur die ersten
bis zur, bis zur Hälfte
der zweiten Staffel habe ich geguckt.
Dort, dort
wo der Detektiv dann
nicht mehr dabei ist.
Bis dahin habe ich geguckt, danach
war ich irgendwie nicht so. Das war irgendwie der beste
der Detektivtyp da.
Ich habe vergessen, wie der heißt.
Und danach hatte ich irgendwie keinen Bock mehr
zu gucken. Ich habe
eh den Hang dazu, dass ich manche Serien anfange
und sie mir zwischendrin nicht mehr gefallen,
weil sie sich in eine andere Richtung entwickeln.
Ich habe beispielsweise erste Staffel, erste
dreiviertel Staffel
von Mr. Robot.
Hab ich, wie man so schön sagt, habe ich
extrem gefeiert.
Mr. Robot, so die ersten dreiviertel
der ersten Staffel. Und danach
von einer richtig geilen
Serie, auch mit
mal wirklich
sinnvoll integriert
im Technikrahmen. Das war schon
gut gemacht bei Mr. Robot.
Es war zwar teilweise ziemlich
namengetroppt.
Hier, ich habe Gnome und du hast KDE
und sowas, was so nie jemand sagen würde
eigentlich. Aber es waren
real existierende Sachen und die technischen
Sachen in Mr. Robot waren wirklich
cool für eine Fernsehserie. Deswegen
haben mir drei Viertel von Mr. Robot extrem gut
gefallen. Und danach
war die Serie einfach nur noch um
Hauptdarsteller hat einen Dachschaden.
Oder habe ich nicht mehr geguckt?
Ich habe
eh so ein paar Serien angefangen und nicht mehr geguckt.
Da habe ich noch
geguckt vor einer Weile. Wie ist das? Black
Sails? Wie ist das?
Black Sails?
Serious? Ja genau.
Da habe ich dann auch nur geguckt bis fragt mich nicht irgendwie Staffel 3.
Wo es dann irgendwie nur noch darum ging
wer
in der Karibik Kolonie was mit
wem hatte und so. Fuck. Alter,
könnt ihr nicht einfach ein gutes
Ende machen, wenn euch nichts mehr einfällt?
Man braucht keine 15 Staffel
und immer noch einen Cliffhanger. Wenn euch nichts mehr
einfällt, dann sagt einfach Bam!
3 Staffeln, gutes Ende, fertig.
Das ist mir lieber als irgendwas,
was sich dann irgendwie über 8, 9,
was auch immer auf Staffeln hinzieht und es ab der 3.
Staffel kacke ist und keine ordentliches
Ende hat.
Könnten wir bitte apprenten, wie
laggy der Nintendo Shop auf der Switch ist?
Ja, darüber können wir apprenten,
aber da habe ich keine Ahnung, wo man die Switch kaum verwende.
Aber ja, der ist laggy.
Dazu fällt mir bloß noch ein,
wie Shop Music,
beste.
Beste, oder?
Du, du, du,
du, du,
du, du, du, du,
beste.
Wie Shop Music.
Exzellent, oder?
Fahrstuhl, nee, nee, nee,
nicht Fahrstuhl Musik. Fahrstuhl Musik ist
so komplettes Gedudel, das ist
so um Gedudel.
Der Meat Channel?
Da kann ich mich jetzt gar nicht mehr
dran erinnern.
Du, du, du, du, doch, genau.
Nee, aber den
wie Shop Music finde ich besser.
Ja, weiß auch nicht, wie ich jetzt darauf
gekommen bin. So, ich wollte den Chat auch
fertig durchgucken, also.
Ja, das stimmt,
Ribolo, du hast schon recht, deswegen verstehe ich
aus technischer Sicht, warum Nintendo auf der
Switch keine Konsole haben will, aber
aus Anwendersicht geht's mir auf den Sack,
dass sie keinen Browser haben, wenn's doch eh schon eine mobile
Konsole ist. Weil, mal ernsthaft,
du musst
die Switch kann ja eh schon an
Zusatzsachen nix. Könnt ihr euch noch
an diese Sache erinnern, mit der Splatoon
App, dass du
Voice Chat über dein Handy machen musstest
und noch nicht mal richtig Lobbys
freuen konntest, über das Handy, so
Nintendo Online Sachen, Alter.
Kann Nintendo
mal 2020, nee, Moment,
Moment, Moment. Nintendo muss nicht
2020 ankommen.
Es würde schon reichen, wenn Nintendo 2008
ankommt, oder 2005,
nämlich beim
Xbox Live für die
360.
Es würde schon reichen,
wenn Nintendo 15 Jahre hinten dran langsam
ankommen würde, was online angeht.
Vollkommen ausreichend.
Okay, jetzt hatten wir schon hier
alles.
Einfach
von den Gifts ab, weiß ich nicht, ob ich das gesehen hab, Freund.
Obwohl, dass hier morgen der Appel auf den Kopf fällt.
Damit hat es ja angeblich
angefangen.
Auch wenn man das bezweifeln darf.
So, ähm, die Musik ist ein bisschen laut.
Oh Leute, es ist 22.10 Uhr.
MonkaS.
Äh, das glaube ich
auch, ja.
Das, das glaube ich
auch. Aber was
wieder, finde ich, viel darüber
sagt, äh, über die
Fähigkeiten und über die
Sache Nintendo und online,
was das angeht.
Ich weiß,
ich weiß, ich weiß,
die Switch hat, die Switch hat ein
Browser, äh, über das
im Hilfe-Menü.
Also du konntest, du konntest glaube ich
in Settings, in Settings-Menü, genau,
da musstest du irgendwie W-LANen und dann
kannst du dich quasi weiterleiten lassen
auf die Anmeldeseite.
Äh, fürs W-LAN und dort kannst du dann Link
einbauen und weiterklicken. Wieso? Ja, das kann ich mir auch dran erinnern.
Also, also mal ehrlich,
dass Nintendo online überhaupt was kostet,
ist schon der Witz.
Guckt euch mal den PS3.
Und ich war nun wirklich kein Fan von PlayStation,
von dieser PlayStation-Network-Geschichte
versus Xbox 360 damals.
Aber guckt euch mal an,
wie gut und kostenlos
im Vergleich zu Switch
das PSN von der PS3 war.
Oder wir reden mal schon gar nicht von
Xbox Live auf der 360, was ja
meilenweit vorne war damals.
Allein schon Voice-Chat, unabhängig vom Spiel.
Aber Nintendo ist noch nicht mal auf dem Stand
von 2005.
Was ist denn los mit Nintendo?
Warum, wie kann das,
ich verstehe nicht, wie eine Firma,
die
permanent
über Jahrzehnte lang
so gute Spiele
macht,
diese Sachen so
komplett verkacken kann,
oder auch verscheißen kann?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Wie ist Sicherheit bei
Siegbier und Co.? Bei WLAN würde ich schon sagen,
dass es... Was?
Also WLAN
und WPA2
hat auch so seine Schwachstellen.
Allerdings würde ich sagen, im Heimbereich
ist das noch alles okay, genau.
Und Siegbier
und WLAN und Z-Wave, Siegbier weiß ich nicht
genau, aber ich vermute mal, dass das ähnlich ist.
Z-Wave hat
da musst du
einen möglichst langen Netzwerk-Key
vergeben und dann
gilt das auch als
verhältnismäßig sicher.
Zumal auch die Sache ist,
dass der Unterschied zwischen Siegbier und WLAN ist,
wenn einer in deinen WLAN in irgendeine Art
und Weise reinkommt, hat er Zugriff auf die ganzen
WLAN-Geräte.
Was dir im schlimmsten Fall passieren kann,
wenn einer dein
Siegbier oder Z-Wave
Key erräht,
weil du eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sieben, acht, neun genommen hast,
der kann gucken, welche Temperatur
auf deiner Terrasse ist
oder ja, sonst was.
Wenn du natürlich Z-Wave
Türschlösser
hast, das ist was anderes. Also hast du
einen Z-Wave, hast du einen Z-Wave
Haustürschloss
und
hast eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf,
sechs, sieben, acht, neun als Netzwerk-Key.
Das ist natürlich dann was anderes.
Kannst du einen Siegbier-Hub empfehlen?
Ja.
Aber mit Vorsicht zu genießen,
weil ich Siegbier selbst
erst seit ein paar Tagen verwende. Ich hatte vorher
die ganze Zeit Z-Wave, aber ich
werde jetzt in Zukunft beides verwenden.
Den Konbi-2-Stick
Raspberry Pi
und dann hast du verschiedene andere Optionen,
was du für Software verwendest. Die einfachste
Sache dürfte das hier sein.
Ich
persönlich bin eher ein Fan von
Home Assistant plus
irgendeiner Siegbier-Zwischen-Schnittstelle
und da kannst du nämlich über Home Assistant
auch alles andere verwalten.
Da machst du nicht nur Siegbier drüber,
da machst du dann auch alle deine WLAN-Schalter,
alle deine Lichter, alle deine
Z-Wave-Geräte, alle deine
China Cloud-Geräte, was auch immer,
kannst du alles drüber machen.
Wie gesagt, als Siegbier-Hub
oder als Basisstation
würde ich sowas hier machen.
Siegbier hat leider im Vergleich zu Z-Wave
das Problem, dass die auf einer recht ungünstigen
Frequenz sind.
Deswegen wird auch überall empfohlen,
wenn man Siegbier
über den Raspberry Pi macht
oder generell wenn man Siegbier über einen USB-Stick macht,
dass man das mit einer USB-Verlängerung
macht. Also sprich, man sollte den Stick
nicht direkt hier reinstecken,
sondern eine 1-2 Meter
USB-Verlängerung nehmen,
dass die
Störsachen hier von
Board nicht irgendwie mit den
Siegbier-Signalen
da irgendwie sich überlagern.
Das wird überall empfohlen.
Ich hab's nicht, es geht trotzdem.
Ja.
Und vielleicht
noch 1-2 IKEA
Repeater, wenn's länger als 10 Meter
werden.
Aber ich bin halt auch ein Fan von
selbst basteln.
Also wenn du so einen fertigen
Siegbier-Hub haben willst mit Web-Interface
und quasi
möglichst easy Bedienung,
da kann ich dir leider nichts empfehlen.
Du hast Interessen-Elektronik
direkt für Siegbier-Hubs.
Ja.
Würde ich wahrscheinlich auch machen.
Also du hast den da.
Du hast den da.
Nicht Konbi.
Raspberry
Den da hast du, ne?
Kann man direkt auf
Raspberry Pi stecken.
Das würde ich auch nehmen, wenn
meine Heimautomatisierung auf einem Raspberry Pi
laufen würde. Meine Heimautomatisierung
läuft allerdings auf dem x86
Intel Low
Power Board.
Kein NUC, aber
Intel x86.
NUC hat kein PC
Express, deswegen hab ich keinen gekauft.
Aber hätte ich
auf einen Raspberry Pi, würde ich das auch verwenden.
Ziemlich sicher.
Wahrscheinlich machen wir morgen oder am Wochenende
machen wir dann den Siegbee
Stream.
Da probieren wir nämlich mal den Kram
aus. Ich hab's jetzt aktuell nur mal
ganz behelfsmäßig angestöpselt,
die Schnelle auf einen Raspberry Pi.
Mal gepairt, das Thermostat
und geguckt, ob's geht.
Geht.
Dann haben wir noch einen anderen Sensor bestellt
und dann werden wir am Wochenende
noch eine von diesen
Steckdosen flaschen, die ich euch eben gezeigt hab,
wo mich das Löten so angepisst hat.
Dann werden wir mal ein bisschen Siegbee-Sachen
ausprobieren, welche
der Software-Sachen
die es dafür gibt, so am besten sind.
Wir probieren mal das aus, was in
Home Assistant eingebaut ist.
Wir probieren mal Siegbee to MQTT
aus und wir probieren mal
Pons aus.
Nicht Dekotz, Dekonz.
Tribulon das Recht
muss off.
Hey Max, habe heute eine M2
SSD eingebaut, bringt es was, FPS
Games von der normalen SSD
auf die M2 zu packen oder ist es marginal?
Kommt auf das Game an, also ich würde mal
sagen sowas wie Warzone, was eh schon abkundtief
hässliches
Nachladen von Texturen und Geometrie hat,
bringt das was?
Normalerweise
bei den meisten anderen Games würde ich sagen
ist jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Aber ich würde es für die
Spiele, die ich häufig spiele, würde ich es machen.
Und wie stehst du zu
Skill-Base-Matchmaking-Cod? Da reg ich
mich drüber aus, wenn ich morgen oder übermorgen die Beta
mal ausprobieren.
Gut Leute, machts gut,
wir sehen uns, bis
die Tage, CU.
Brauchen wir Autromusik?
Alles klar, machts gut CU.
Slowly.
Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuhören.